Ey, läuft nicht wieder.
Doch, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht's wieder.
Jetzt kann man's einstellen.
Bug, Bug bei 48 FPS.
Also Leute, F5.
Jetzt kann man's einstellen.
Das liegt an 48 FPS.
Das ging die ganze Zeit.
Jetzt buggt Twitch anscheinend gerade rum.
Geil.
Okay, Leute.
Dann würde ich sagen, legen wir mal los.
Ich geh jetzt nochmal schnell aufs Klo.
Ähm.
Ich mach aber das Game schon mal an.
Weil die Intro-Musik ist schon wieder grandios von dem Spiel.
Ich hab echt, oh scheiße, Leute.
Ich hab übelst Angst vor dem Game.
Jetzt ernsthaft.
Also ich übertreib jetzt nicht, ne.
Das Game, das ist so mitreißend, dass...
Ich war fertig mit den Nerven, als ich das das erste Mal gespielt hab.
Ich war komplett durch.
Und das jetzt noch mit Zuschauern dabei.
Äh.
Das ist ein bisschen schepp, das Fenster.
Oh, das Soundtrack.
Leute, das Soundtrack ist so toll.
Hört euch das mal an.
Ich muss mal kurz das Fenster einstellen.
Das buggt ein bisschen.
Wir haben's gleich.
Aber das Soundtrack ist wirklich grandios.
An dem Soundtrack hat übrigens die Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies mitgeschrieben.
Oder ich war in das ernst.
Könnt ihr mal gucken, wer an den beiden Soundtracks beteiligt war.
4 zu 3 in 2K18, lull.
Cry Cam.
Excuse Cry Cam.
Okay, Leute.
Ähm.
Ich bin mal ganz kurz auf dem Klo.
Ich bin sofort wieder da.
Ähm.
Könnte bitte einer von den Mods schauen, ob Kategorie, also sprich, ob Spielkategorie und Sprache auf Deutsch steht und sowas.
Ob das alles passt.
Weil wir haben ja gestern bei Twitch gesehen, dass es nicht immer so gut funktioniert.
Lautstärke okay, Jungs.
Und Mädels.
Natürlich.
Wir respektieren ja Frauen.
Okay.
Oh, Mann.
Ich hab echt Schiss vor dem Game.
Auf geht's.
So, die Vorschau gucken, ob das alles passt.
Also, der Anfang ist ein bisschen gemächlich.
Da wird das, klar, so ein bisschen als Intro.
Ich hab's ja schon mal gespielt.
Der Anfang ist ein bisschen gemächlich, aber man muss aufpassen, weil viele Sachen, die man so sieht nebenbei,
ähm, ergeben später Sinn.
Nicht, dass man es unbedingt braucht, um es zu checken, ja.
Die Story an sich versteht man auch so.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Und das ist wirklich eine...
Das ist eine super Geschichte.
Also, ich finde, das ist das, jetzt mal ohne zu übertreiben, ja.
Das ist das bestgeschriebenste Spiel, was ich in den letzten zehn Jahren gespielt habe.
Auf geht's.
Und es ist ein RPG-Maker-Spiel.
Dementsprechend sieht's doch aus.
Allerdings, äh, mit komplett von Hand erstellter Craft, also von Sprites.
Echt gut.
Oh, zum Glück.
Ich hab gerade noch kurz überlegt.
Hab ich's auf Deutsch gestellt?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber zum Glück.
Ey, ey, ey, ey.
MonkaS.
Ähm, ich bin mir übrigens noch...
Das muss ich jetzt nochmal erzählen, bevor wir...
Bevor wir anfangen, weil das Spiel hat relativ viel Text.
Also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich alles vorlese, ja.
Also, sag mal so, die Hauptdialog lese ich vor.
Allerdings, ähm, wenn ich jetzt mit irgendeinem random NPC labere oder so, keine Ahnung, ob ich den vorlese.
Also, da sind die zwei.
Dr. Rosaline, wo bist du mit deinen Gedanken, Nile?
Entschuldige vielmals.
Ich bin...
Oh, das ist übelst schwierig für mich.
Ich hab überhaupt keine Let's-Play-Erfahrung großartig.
Der Cringe ist real, Alter.
Entschuldige vielmals, dass ich hellnav versucht habe, dem plötzlich auftauchenden Eichhörnchen auszuweichen.
Das ist der übelste Schwätzer, der Typ.
Du hast es trotzdem überfahren.
Verstell die Stimme, please.
Ach, ich kann das nicht.
Ich kann das nicht.
Ich kann nicht hier auf den übelst krassen Let's-Play-Stelzer warten.
Oh.
Du hast es überfahren.
Und bist gegen den Baum geknallt.
Naja, nicht so schlimm.
Der Wagen gehört der Agentur.
Hast du Witze?
Der Chef wird uns umbringen.
Hm, wir sagen einfach, ich hätte einen Hundenwelpen gerettet.
Er mag doch kleine Hunde, oder?
Mag er.
Sieht man im zweiten Teil.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Es gibt übrigens schon einen zweiten Teil von dem Game.
Nennt sich Finding Paradise.
Er ist eher ein Katzen-Typ.
Nee, er mag Hunde.
Erinnere ich mich noch.
Ich bin dran.
Warum muss immer alles so kompliziert sein?
Na gut, wir haben so ein Lieblings-Feldknoll gerettet.
So, Krise abgewendet.
Gut, das kannst du ja alles so in den Bericht schreiben.
Lass uns die Ausrüstung aus dem Wagen holen und losgehen.
Die Steuerung ist äußerst simpel.
Point and Click.
Ausrüstung.
Yeah.
Habt das, Mystic, lasst uns losgehen.
Ähm.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich das erste Mal in Deutsch gespielt habe.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Gucken wir uns mal das Eichhörnchen nochmal an.
Tracked.
Ausweich und das Auto nicht zu Schrott fahren.
Das ist ein bisschen viel verlangt.
Übrigens, Fun Fact.
Im zweiten Teil fährt sie Auto am Anfang.
Hey, warte mal.
Was ist mit dem Auto?
Ich wollte nur sicher gehen, dass du es nicht vergisst.
Wie du immer an mich denkst.
Vor allem, ne?
Range von diesem Türschließer.
GG, der Spoiler.
Es gibt, es gibt generell ein paar Referenzen auf den ersten Teil im zweiten, wobei der zweite Teil ist, es, es ist nicht wirklich ein zweiter Teil, ne, also es ist komplett neu, halt die, die zwei Ärzte sind die Gleichen.
Wer hat da einen Felsbrocken hingelegt?
Vielleicht ist das ihr Sicherheitssystem.
Oh Gott, die Übersetzung.
So, guck hier nochmal.
Unsere Zeit ist zu kostbar für solchen Blödsinn.
Versuchen wir ihn aus dem Weg zu rollen.
Erst.
Let's go.
Moment.
Hm.
Oder wir machen einfach Feierabend und geben diesen Ding nicht schuld.
Nein.
Easy.
Auf drei.
Das hast du doch auch gesehen.
Was war das?
Kein Felsbrocken, so viel steht fest.
Naja, wir müssen sowieso weiter.
Wir können später nochmal darüber nachdenken.
Ja, genau.
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Das hat er echt schön, das haben sie echt schön gemacht.
Ich meine, für das, dass es ein RPG Maker Game ist.
Der Leuchtturm.
Ja, ich kann mich dran erinnern.
Oh Gott, das wird schlimm.
Das wird schlimm.
Für das, dass es ein RPG Maker Game ist, haben sie sich wirklich verdammt viel Mühe gegeben.
Hello.
Herein.
Das mattert nicht.
Sie sind da.
Okay, ich muss jetzt, ich muss jetzt Girls Stimme machen, aber das kann ich nicht.
Die ganzen krassen Let's Player können das.
Die können für jeden Charakter eine unterschiedliche Stimme machen.
Ich kann das nicht.
Ich hab es nicht so gut.
So mit Let's Play normalerweise.
Ihr wisst ja, ich hab zwei Let's Plays geschafft.
Über drei Jahre oder so.
Moin, Scary Lecky.
Kein schlechter Ort, um in Rente zu gehen, was?
Da geht noch was.
Nachtschichten. Liebst du oder hast du sie?
Du kennst die Antwort, du verdammte Nachteule.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich wieder eine Nacht durchmachen müssen, weißt du?
Ist mir klar.
Und ich bezweifle, dass sie Kaffee haben.
Oh, sie haben Kaffee.
Halt die Klappe.
Alter, Lan.
Und das wehres Rauschen wird unsere Ohren sanft umspielen.
Der Typ erzählt einen Blödsinn immer.
Davon krieg ich nichts mit, wenn du so viel laberst.
So, auf geht's. Rein.
Vergiss nicht die Ausrüstung.
Da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Für das werden sie viel zu schlecht bezahlt.
Dr. Watts und Dr. Rosalie nehme ich an.
Danke, dass sie so kurzfristig her konnten.
Kein Problem, ich bin selbst nicht so gut darin, Tote vorherzusagen.
Was?
Habe ich mich da gerade verlesen?
Sind sie die Tochter des Patienten?
Oh nein, ich bin nur die Pflegerin.
Die deutsche Übersetzung ist, soweit ich weiß, von Fans beigesteuert.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts Offizielles.
Das sind meine Kinder, Sarah und Tommy.
Ich habe nicht gerade einen 8-Stunden-Job, deshalb erlaubt uns Johnny, hier zu wohnen.
Ich nehme an, dieser Johnny ist unser Mann.
Johnny?
Hören Sie, wenn wir es hier mit einem Kind zu tun haben, dann sind wir nicht die Richtigen für Sie.
Nein, nein, er möchte nur lieber so genannt werden.
Er ist oben, sein Arzt ist gerade bei ihm.
Kommen Sie bitte mit.
Also dann, schnappt ihr den Koffer und los geht's.
Wenn mein Rücken eines Tages schlapp macht, verklage ich dich auf Schadensersatz.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel, dass es nicht viel Sinn macht, hier am Anfang rumzulaufen und zu gucken.
Da ist noch nicht viel.
Okay, ab nach oben, bevor ich dieses Ding noch fallen lasse.
Bis jetzt hat man noch keine Ahnung, was die beiden hier eigentlich machen.
Ich hoffe, ich bin mir nämlich nicht mehr sicher, wie gut das das Game erklärt.
Nach oben, jo.
Aber nachdem es der erste Teil ist, glaube ich, war das gut.
Ich habe es komplett gecheckt.
Okay, sie sind weg.
Wer zuerst da ist, darf die Melodie spielen.
Der Soundtrack ist so toll.
De de de de de de.
Okay, jetzt ist es Absicht, dass der Sound ein bisschen leiser ist, weil es von unten kommt.
Für ihr Alter sind diese Kinder ziemlich gut.
Ey, du bist diejenige, die hier ständig erzählt, dass wir keine Zeit haben.
Go, go, go.
Wobei ich rein zufällig derjenige bin, der das Gewicht eines kleinen Meteoriten durch die Gegend schleppen darf.
Ja, ja, auf geht's.
Oh, ich erinnere mich wieder an das Game, ey.
Es hat mich jubelnd fertig gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich das Spiel gehen kann.
Das ist Johnny.
Und das ist der Doktor.
Der übrigens auch in Finding Paradise vorkommt.
Wollen sie aufbauen?
Erstmal umsehen.
Wollen wir absetzen oder wollen wir uns umsehen?
Wollen wir direkt loslegen oder wollen wir erstmal ein bisschen im Haus rumgucken?
Ich glaube, da gab es nicht viel.
Ich setze erst mal umsehen.
Ich will nämlich nochmal gucken, was hier drin war.
Nix.
Okay, dann legen wir gleich los.
Wollen wir erstmal nochmal mit dem Doktor reden.
Er ist nicht mehr ansprechbar.
Aber wie es aussieht, tut er sein Bestes, um bei uns zu bleiben.
Hallo, Ghost QQ.
Schwer zu sagen, wie viel Zeit Ihnen bleibt, aber ich würde mich beeilen.
Maschine absetzen.
Jawoll.
Ja doch, man kriegt am Anfang erklärt, was die beiden eigentlich machen und vorhaben.
Ich muss mal kurz schnell checken, ob das Sound, die Lautstärke so passt.
Aber ich denke, ne?
Ja.
Die Spiele-Lautstärke ist gut, oder?
Sind Sie sicher, dass eine normale Steckdose für Ihre Zwecke ausreicht?
Keine Sorge, wir sind die Fachleute.
Doch, ist angenehm.
Okay, Sie brauchen...
Mist.
Strom aus.
Reine Routine.
Ich teste nur, ob ihr aufpasst.
Wie macht er sich?
Nicht so gut, wenn Sie mich fragen.
Er hat noch ein oder zwei Tage.
Das ist reichlich Zeit.
Ja genau, jetzt kriegt man es ein bisschen erklärt.
Sie beide können ihm also jeden Wunsch erfüllen, ja?
Wir können es zumindest versuchen.
Bis jetzt haben wir es immer geschafft.
Denn wir sind einfach der Wahnsinn.
Er findet sich halt einfach geil.
Also, wie lautet der Wunsch?
Der Mond.
Der Mond?
WTF?
Der Mond.
Er möchte zum Mond fliegen.
Und deswegen heißt das Spiel To The Moon.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Die alten Knacker werden auch immer abgedreht, oder was?
Also, ist das möglich?
Kommt drauf an.
Das Wort, das du suchst, heißt Ja.
Warum erzählen Sie uns nicht ein wenig über unsere Kunden hier?
Tja, ich weiß eigentlich nicht sehr viel.
Johnny ist ein seltsamer Mann.
In den zwei Jahren, die ich hier gearbeitet habe, hat er kaum gesprochen.
Er hat sein Leben lang als Handwerker gearbeitet und seine Frau ist vor zwei Jahren gestorben.
Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Hör mir doch mal an.
Ich hätte mehr erfahren, wenn ich seine verdammte...
Was, wenn ich sein verdammter Zeitungsjunge wäre?
Mach einfach deine Arbeit.
Nun ja, ich denke, wenn Sie sich im Haus umsehen, können Sie noch einiges über ihn erfahren.
Johnny hätte sicher nichts dagegen.
Er hat Sie beide ja schließlich beauftragt.
Gut, dann machen wir das.
Also, wer von uns beiden spielt Detektiv?
Ähm...
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal bin ich mit Dr. What's losgelaufen.
Jetzt nehme ich ja Dr. Rosalind.
Wie gesagt, am Anfang ist das ein bisschen gemächlich.
Aber man muss sich ein paar Sachen merken.
Danke für das Angebot.
Aber ich bin voll damit ausgelastet, einen Backenabdruck auf diesem Stuhl zu hinterlassen.
Das könnte ich auch.
Gut, weitermachen.
Tommy und Sarah können Sie herumführen.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich unten.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich unten am Klavier.
Gehen wir mal gucken.
Leute, ich muss schon wieder aufs Klo.
Lull.
Warten Sie, kommen Sie doch einmal kurz her.
Ich habe hier etwas für Sie.
Hier, nehmen Sie das.
Kabelloser Kontrollmonitor.
Damit wissen Sie jederzeit, wie es Johnny geht.
Danke, ich wollte Sie gerade danach fragen.
Ach genau, jetzt sieht man das hier oben.
Nicht, dass es wirklich für das Game relevant wäre.
Wir speichern mal.
Hast du die Tränendrüsen am Darmausgang?
Nein.
Nein, noch ist ja nichts passiert.
Twitch-Berserker, das stimmt.
So, jetzt wenn hier gerade Musik läuft, ich muss noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
So, wieder am Start.
Leute, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Und zwar, soll ich noch eine Ankündigung posten für den Stream, also sprich Twitter oder vielleicht auf diese YouTube Community Geschichte?
Oder wollt ihr lieber im kleinen Kreis bleiben?
Quasi die Leute, die Twitch
folgen und hier über Twitch
reinkommen.
Was ist euch lieber?
So bleiben oder noch ein paar
Leute dazu?
Gehen wir mal zu Sarah und Tommy.
Sarah, was wollen sie?
Führ mich durchs Haus.
Jo.
Bist du eine kleine Runde dem Stil?
Ich verdiene überhaupt nichts hier dran.
Goal is QQ. Gar nichts.
Führt mich durchs Haus.
Sarah und Tommy, richtig?
Eure Mutter meint,
ihr könnt mich einmal durchs Haus führen.
Okay, vielleicht machen wir das.
Okay, es sind alle für
im kleinen Kreis. Dann lassen wir das.
Vielleicht später auf Twitter.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen einfach ein bisschen
Überzeugung. Das ist alles.
Oh, was meinst du, Tommy?
Oh, ich weiß, die Kinder gingen mir voll auf den Sack
beim ersten Mal durchspielen.
Was möchtet ihr denn?
Wir wollen eine Trillion Dollar.
Easy clap.
Ohne die Zuckerstange,
die Mama vor uns versteckt.
Ja, oder wie?
What?
Da ist eine riesengroße Zuckerstange
oben in dem Regalfach, an das wir nicht rankommen.
Sie liegt in der Küche.
Mama hat sie dort
vor uns versteckt, bis wir unsere
Hausaufgaben gemacht haben.
Holen Sie sie für uns und wir machen mit Ihnen eine Tour durchs Haus.
Wie sieht's aus?
Also ich bin ja ganz ehrlich für
lass den Mist und kommt mit.
Oh Gott, das funktioniert.
Wirklich.
Zehn Stück.
Easy.
Funktioniert.
Oder zwölf?
Nicht mehr als fünf.
Die haben sehr viele Kalorien.
Ja, krass.
Haha.
Das würde mich jetzt weniger interessieren.
Immer noch besser als eine.
Auf geht's.
Ja, dann führt mich mal rum.
Okay, wo fangen wir an?
Dieser seltsame Raum im Keller.
Ich mag den seltsamen Raum nicht.
Was meint ihr mit seltsamer Raum?
Sie werden schon sehen.
Er ist gruselig.
Wir brauchen aber die Schlüssel.
Der alte Mann hat sie in einem Buch im Arbeitszimmer versteckt.
Okay, wo ist das Arbeitszimmer?
Das ist das Bad.
Was haben wir hier?
Nix.
Licht.
Na gut, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht wirklich.
Keller.
Im Keller können wir nicht.
Moment.
Hä?
Hat er nicht gerade gesagt, ich soll ins Arbeitszimmer und den Schlüssel holen?
Das ist der Keller.
Hier spielen wir immer verstecken.
Verstecken.
Schalten Sie das Licht an, damit wir nicht stolpern.
Machen wir.
Tür ist verschlossen.
Okay, wir brauchen den Schlüssel.
Ich habe mich gerade spontan dazu entschlossen.
Ich lese nicht jedes Dialogfenster vor.
Sondern nur die Haupt-, nur die wichtigen.
So, wir können hier unten nichts machen.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal den Schlüssel holen.
Die Tür ist abgeschlossen.
Ist das hier das richtige Zimmer?
Ja.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt...
Wir müssen das mit dem Schlüssel besorgen.
Wo geht es hier lang?
Ich kann mich dann immer so richtig daran erinnern.
Das ist der Bücherraum.
Der Schlüssel für den seltsamen Raum ist im dicksten Buch des oberen Regals.
Na, wie praktisch, dass der Raum genau nebendran ist.
Nein.
Das lesen wir jetzt nicht.
Nope.
Im dicksten Buch.
Das ist doch das dickste Buch.
Zimmerschlüssel.
Jawoll.
Weiter geht's.
Jetzt gehen wir in den gruseligen Raum im Keller.
Worum geht es in dem Game?
Also ja, Point & Click Adventure ist das neue...
Ne, das Game ist von 2015.
Also es geht darum, dass Johnny, der oben im Bett liegt...
...und ungefähr nur noch 1-2 Tage zu leben hat...
...einen Wunsch hat.
Er möchte auf den Mond.
Und...
...die beiden hier, also aktuell sieht man hier nur Dr. Rosaline, der andere sitzt oben...
...sind von einer Firma, die eine Maschine besitzen...
...mit dem man quasi Johnnys Gehirn umprogrammieren kann...
...dass er denkt, er war auf dem Mond.
Und sich so seinen letzten Wunsch erfüllen kann, obwohl es in echt nicht passiert ist.
Allerdings müssen sie dazu rauskriegen...
...was in Johnnys Vergangenheit so passiert ist, um das Ganze neu programmieren zu können.
So.
Die Tür wurde aufgeschlossen.
Das ist ja wie in einer Höhle.
Wir nehmen das mal mit.
Ein Hase aus Papier gefaltet.
Die sind wichtig nachher, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die Hasen kommen noch öfters vor.
Haben sie es gesehen?
Was wisst ihr zwei über die ganzen Papierhasen?
Nix.
Der alte Mann wollte nicht, dass jemand reingeht, also haben wir es ihm nie gesagt.
Es gibt sogar noch mehr davon.
Wo?
Im verlassenen Leuchtturm.
Der ist direkt an der Klippe.
Wollen wir hingehen? Ich hab die Schlüssel.
Dahin solltet ihr natürlich auch nicht gehen, oder?
Lol.
Erinnert mich daran, euch zwei niemals in Niles Wohnung mitzunehmen.
Also, wollen wir zum Leuchtturm.
Ist ganz schön kalt draußen, aber...
Zum Leuchtturm gehen.
Oder hier bleiben wir auf die Maschine warten.
Leute, was wollen wir machen?
Gehen oder warten?
Chat-Interaktion in 2K18, lol.
Seit wann läuft der Stream?
Oh...
Eine halbe Stunde?
Warten zum Leuchtturm...
Campen.
Der Sibaro ist ein Mod.
Und...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Sibaro ist Mod.
Das zählt dann mehr als...
Aber...
Jetzt schreiben wir alle warten.
Warten, ok.
Warten wir.
Wenn Johnny für die Hasen verantwortlich ist, dann werde ich in seiner Erinnerung vermutlich sowieso davon erfahren.
WWPD.
Ich habe gerade gefragt im Chat, ob die Leute lieber kleine Runde haben wollen oder mit Ankündigung.
Und das waren alle für kleine Runde.
Also, ab nach oben. Mal sehen, ob Nile mit dem Konfigurieren der Maschine fertig ist.
Für River.
Was ist denn das für ein Lied?
Es hat nur zwei Noten, die sich ständig wiederholen.
Für River.
Von Johnny H. Wilds.
Lutz.
Du hast noch nicht viel...
Ne, du hast wirklich nicht viel verpasst.
Ne, ne.
Wir haben noch gar nicht richtig angefangen.
Und auch, so wirklich erklärt, was die zwei hier machen, wurde auch noch nicht so komplett abschließend.
Du hast noch gar nichts verpasst, eigentlich.
Sag mal, warum kommst du nicht noch ein bisschen später?
Ist nicht so, als ob der Kunde wegschließt.
Ist nicht so, als ob der Kunde wegsterben könnte oder so.
Ich muss noch was erledigen.
Ich muss auch was erledigen, nämlich unser Job.
Jetzt komm mal von deinem hohen Ross.
Ich bin einmal zu spät und ziehst dich gleich daran hoch.
Sag mir wenigstens, dass wir startklar sind.
Natürlich sind wir das.
Ich verstehe mein Handwerk.
Wie geil er sich findet.
Der Helm ist auf der Couch. Hopp, hopp.
Ach, hier ist eine Couch.
Ich würde sagen, wo ist hier eine Couch?
Guck mal, was die Angehörigen sagen, wobei die Pflegerin...
Übrigens, entschuldigen Sie meine Neugier.
Wie funktioniert das?
Schreiben Sie ihm einfach...
Ah, das ist gut.
Jetzt...
Okay, das ist gut zur Erklärung, dass man eigentlich versteht, was hier passiert.
Wie funktioniert das?
Schreiben Sie ihm einfach ein neues Leben, so wie man einen Roman schreibt, erklären.
Nein, man kann neue Erinnerungen nicht einfach aus dem Nichts erschaffen.
Und wie macht man das?
Nicht wir.
Das meiste erledigt die Maschine.
Wir werden nicht gut genug bezahlt, um uns selbst die Hände schmutzig zu machen.
Kurz gefasst, unser Job ist es, so tief wie möglich in seine frühesten Erinnerungen vorzudrängen.
Dort angekommen, werden wir dann sein registriertes Verlangen nach einem Flug zum Mond
auf die Rekonstruktion seiner Umgebung und seines Selbst in diesem früheren Zustand übertragen.
Und mit der Hilfe eines Wikis allgemeiner und persönlicher Daten simuliert die Maschine dann eine Wiederholung.
Nur wird ihn diesmal die Motivation aus seinem registrierten Verlangen sein ganzes Leben lang begleiten.
Also hängt alles davon ab, dass er sich seinen Wunsch selbst erfüllt.
Einfach weil er das Verlangen danach hat.
Wie soll das gehen?
Wir streben doch alle nach irgendwas im Leben, aber kaum jemand erreicht sein Ziel.
Nun, in der realen Welt sind Wünsche und Ambitionen im ständigen Fluss, sie entstehen und vergehen.
Jetzt ist hier ja Philosophie hier auf Vorlesung, oder wie?
Die Leidenschaft führt die Menschen auf ihren Weg.
Aber dann kommt ihnen das erste Feuer abhanden und sie werden träge.
Oh ja, das kenne ich. Ich wäre auch träge.
Stellen Sie sich vor, diese erste brennende Leidenschaft wäre immer bei Ihnen, ihr ganzes Leben lang, ohne nachzulassen.
Es mag nicht so scheinen, aber das hat eine gewaltige Kraft.
Wo wir davon sprechen, keine Kraft der Welt wird einem toten Mann helfen können.
Ich fange also besser an.
Oh, natürlich.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also für alle, die neu dabei sind.
Mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst.
Ah, wir sehen es jetzt ja auch.
Das ist Johnny, der hier im Bett liegt.
Und wir sind Dr. Rosaline und Dr. Niall Watts.
Was ist das jetzt?
Wie heißt Rosaline eigentlich? Eva. Eva heißt sie, genau.
Und sie sind hier, um Johnny seinen letzten Wunsch zu erfüllen.
Allerdings nicht wirklich, und das ist das, was auch gerade dieser Dialog da erklären sollte.
Sie haben eine Maschine dabei, die quasi Johnnys Hirn umprogrammieren kann.
Dass er eben denkt, er hat sich seinen letzten Wunsch erfüllt, ohne dass es in der echten Welt passiert ist.
Und jetzt geht's eigentlich erst richtig los.
Bereit oder nicht? Wir starten durch.
Oh, das Spiel war so traurig.
Ich hab echt Schiss.
Ich hab echt Schiss, dass ich jetzt gleich übelst rumheulen muss im Stream.
Das sollte die letzte erreichbare Erinnerung sein.
Hier oben sieht man übrigens, wie weit wir in Johnnys Leben sind.
Also aktuell sind wir noch ziemlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, kurz bevor er gestorben ist.
Äh, Quatsch. Kurz an das Letzte, woran er sich erinnern kann.
Er ist ja noch nicht gestorben, sonst könnten wir das Ganze hier nicht machen.
Vergesst einfach, was ich erzähle. Blödsinn.
Das sollte die letzte erreichbare Erinnerung sein.
Deaktiviere die Sprache für alle außer Johnny.
Schnappen wir ihn uns.
Ah, jetzt kriegt man es ja sogar nochmal erklärt.
Die Position in der Zeitleiste lässt sich jederzeit mit dem Mauszeiger im oberen Bildschirm anzeigen.
Genau. Also sprich, wie weit wir in den Erinnerungen sind.
Aktuell sind wir noch nicht so weit in der Vergangenheit.
Und das Schöne ist, dass man hier eben schneller läuft.
Als in echt.
Als also in der echten Welt hier in dem Spiel dann.
Wo ist denn Johnny?
Und man sieht hier auch, in den Erinnerungen ist halt nicht alles ausgebaut.
Also sprich, an die Sachen, wo er sich nicht mehr erinnern kann, sieht man halt nichts mehr.
Aber Hauptsache, wir können die Lichter noch an- und ausschalten.
Wo steckt Johnny?
Ne, hier geht es nicht mehr weiter.
Johnny ist am Leuchtturm.
Garantiert ist Johnny da.
Johnny am Leuchtturm.
Johnny?
John.
Jetzt ist es John.
Was für eine schöne Überraschung. Wir haben hier selten einen Besuch.
Also für alle, die jetzt dazu kommen, das ist die Erinnerung von Johnny.
Dementsprechend ist hier vieles nicht so wirklich wie in echt.
Mein Name ist Dr. Eva Rosaline und das ist...
Dr. von Meddard nicht.
Dr. von Matterhorn.
Dr. Lorenzo von Matterhorn.
Dr. Neil Watts.
Ich bin der Name Sigmund Agency of Life Generation geläufig.
Oh, also sind Sie beiden von der Agentur.
Das trifft sich gut. Ich habe gerade überlegt, Sie anzurufen.
Ja, Johnny, das hast du auch.
Lilly, bring uns etwas Tee.
Lilly?
Nun, um genau zu sein, haben Sie uns bereits angerufen.
Wir sind hier, um unseren Vertrag aus der nahen Zukunft zu erfüllen.
Vorsicht, wenn Sie von der Klippe stürzen, müssen wir diese Erinnerung neu laden.
Er ist immer so feinfühlig, ja?
Zeig etwas Respekt.
Es ist seine letzte erreichbare Erinnerung, also brauchen wir seine Hilfe.
Im schlimmsten Fall laden wir sie einfach neu.
Sie... Sie sind hier, um mich zum Mond zu bringen, oder?
Ja, John.
Mein Leben ist eigentlich ganz gut verlaufen.
Nicht gut genug, wie es aussieht.
Oh, er ist so feinfühlig, Dr. Watts.
Also, können Sie das?
Können Sie mich zum Mond bringen?
Wir nicht, aber Sie selbst können es vielleicht.
Warum wollen Sie eigentlich dorthin?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und ohne zu spoilern, Leute.
Man weiß es eine verdammt lange Zeit in diesem Spiel nicht, warum Johnny eigentlich zum Mond will.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so in einem Game geheult,
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man rauskriegt, warum Johnny zum Mond will.
Das Spiel ist wirklich super geschrieben.
So, weiter.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Sorge, Sie können es uns ruhig sagen.
Wir müssen es wissen, damit wir Ihnen helfen können.
Wollen Sie Ruhm? Das Geld?
Es muss doch einen Grund geben, warum Sie zum Mond wollen.
Tut mir leid, aber ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Ich will es einfach.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich diesen Auftrag hassen werde.
Nun gut, Johnny.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, was wir tun werden.
Wir müssen in Ihre Kindheitserinnerungen gelangen.
Die liegen weit zurück, zu weit für einen einzelnen Erinnerungssprung.
Deshalb werden wir schrittweise durch Ihre Erinnerungen in die Vergangenheit reisen.
Sie haben uns dafür in naher Zukunft schon die Erlaubnis gegeben.
Das beruhigen zu wissen.
Sobald wir einen direkten Zugang zu Ihren Kindheitserinnerungen hergestellt haben, kehren wir hierher zurück.
Dann kommt der Moment, an dem Sie uns helfen müssen, Ihre Kindheitserinnerungen zurückzuführen.
Ihre Kindheit so zu beeinflussen, dass Sie später Astronaut werden.
Oder sich einen Riesenkatapult besorgen.
Klar ist aber, Sie müssen mehr dafür tun, als ich weiß es nicht zu sagen.
Solange Sie mich zum Mond bringen, werde ich tun, was ich kann.
Ok.
Folgendes.
Um in die Vergangenheit zu springen, brauchen wir ein Memento.
Einen Gegenstand, der für Sie einen hohen Erinnerungswert hat.
Haben Sie etwas für uns?
Hm.
Geht der Chat noch?
Ja.
Ihr seht, das ist einer von diesen Hasen, ne?
Das sollte gehen.
Nun, sollen wir?
Ladies first.
Also, man muss echt mal sagen, für das, dass es ein RPG Maker Spiel ist, ne?
Sieht echt gut aus.
Notizmond erhalten.
Wir müssen zuerst das Memento vorbereiten.
Vorbereiten.
Bereiten wir vor.
Jetzt kommen irgendwelche sinnlosen Minigames, die aber mega easy sind.
Was?
Kugel anklicken, um Elemente zu drehen.
Äh.
Ja.
Easy clap.
Hochgradig schwieriges Minigame.
Gedächtnissprung kann aktiviert werden.
Ok.
Weiter geht's.
Moment.
Was ist mit meiner Privatsphäre?
Gute Frage, Johnny.
Die NSA liest mit.
Wir versuchen, sie so wenig wie möglich zu verletzen.
Ähm.
Sbarro sehe ich auch so.
Sbarro hat gerade geschrieben, ich glaube, wenn das Game in der CryEngine oder Frostbite wäre, würde es viel an seiner Atmosphäre verlieren.
Ja.
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, jetzt in Videos und Livestreams.
Ich kann so 2D-Sprites, kann ich viel mehr Emotionen abnehmen, als 3D-Models.
Liegt wohl an mir.
Aber.
3D-Models kann ich kaum Emotionen abnehmen.
Auch so in Heavy Rain oder so.
Das war alles jetzt nicht sonderlich emotional, ja.
Ok.
Aber meistens lässt es sich nicht ganz vermeiden.
Die Privatsphäre.
Zu verletzen.
Von Johnny.
So viele Hasen.
Es wäre nervig gesehen zu werden.
Zufrieden?
Wie lang ist das Spiel?
3-4 Stunden?
Mein Gott, was sollen bloß diese ganzen Hasen?
Der Soundtrack ist echt schön zu dem Game.
Da kriege ich ja eine Gänsehaut.
Wir hätten vorher in seiner Akte nach psychopathischen Veranlagungen schauen sollen.
Was zum?
The fuck?
Hat er mich gehört?
Das ist unmöglich.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nur ein Teil seiner Erinnerung.
Dann bleibe ich bei meiner Argumentation.
Was geht mit Johnny ab?
Wie auch immer, hör auf zu quatschen und finde ein Memento, das uns von hier wegbringt.
Stimmt.
Der Hase hat Farbe, der Rest nicht.
So, um jetzt weiter zurück in die Vergangenheit zu kommen, muss man die Erinnerung untersuchen.
Das ist aber recht interaktiv meistens.
Also meistens gibt es dann irgendwas, wo halt die Geschichte voranbringt.
Nicht einfach nur irgendwas sinnlos anklicken.
Ein alter, gepflegter Rucksack.
Stammt der aus der Steinzeit?
Das werden wir gleich herausfinden.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das Kaisers neue Kleider von Hans Christian Andersen.
Johnny steht auf das harte Zeug.
Die zurzeitige Overwatch League ist nicht so deins, oder?
Doch, doch, ich gucke.
Was macht denn Johnny hier?
Leere Bilder.
Lass es, wenn wir ihm unsere Anwesenheit in jeder Erinnerung neu erklären müssen, drehe ich durch.
Führe mich nicht in Versuchung.
Okay, was habe ich hier übersehen?
Gehen wir mal wieder runter.
Es geht bestimmt unten weiter.
Regenschirm?
Ach ne, mit dem Regenschirm geht es dann weiter, okay.
Die Uhr läuft, aber man hört keinen Ticken.
Ah, okay.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen mehr meine Maus über alles mögliche drüber machen.
Den habe ich schon untersucht, ne?
Okay, dann habe ich oben irgendwas vergessen anzuschauen.
Die Uhr läuft, aber man hört keinen Ticken.
Oh, ein Glas.
Ein Glas eingelegter Oliven.
Bäh.
Was gibt es daran zu hassen?
Das sind eingelegte Oliven.
Genau das.
Äh, ah, Buch.
Ah, die Blumen unten.
Frische Wildblumen.
Okay, wir haben alles entdeckt.
Dann reisen wir mal weiter in die Vergangenheit von Johnny.
Oh.
The Grinch is real.
Dr.
Watts.
Max, spielst du nachher eine Runde StarCraft?
Nein, ich habe ewig kein StarCraft.
Was?
Nein, ich habe ewig kein StarCraft mehr gespielt.
WTF war das?
Was denn?
Genug davon.
Ab jetzt übernehme ich das tischmettern der Barriere.
Die Minispieler haben mich genervt.
Als ich das erste mal durchgespielt habe es weiß ich noch.
Ich habe dann irgendwann einfach nur sinnlos herum geklickt.
Weiter.
Ich mag Regen lieber, wenn er durch mich statt auf mich fällt.
Mir macht er so oder so nichts aus.
Scheint so, als würden die Erinnerungssprünge pray out.
Scheint so, als würden die Erinnerungssprünge points ut.
Immer nur einen kleinen Zeitraum überbrücken.
Wir müssen ein passendes Memento finden, sonst brauchen wir nur Ewigkeiten.
Ach, genieß doch einfach die Landschaft.
Geht's hier irgendwo hin?
Ne, geht's nicht weiter.
Guck mal, Johnny hat dieses komische Ding dabei.
Das Plüschnabeltier.
Ich mein, wer hat kein Plüschnabeltier?
Ernsthaft, dieses Tier sollte nicht das Recht haben zu existieren.
Die Welt ist nicht groß genug für zwei von eurer Sorte.
Was macht Johnny hier?
In Gedanken an River E. Wiles.
Sagen wir einfach mal, in Gedanken an River.
Tja, wer ist denn River?
Noch wissen wir es nicht.
Es ist fertig, River.
Wie du, so kann ich auch...
Wie du, so kann auch ich nun jeden Tag auf sie aufpassen.
Was auf das Plüschtier?
Sie wird nicht mehr alleine sein.
Was ist das denn?
Ich werde vielleicht niemals verstehen, warum.
Aber ich hab deinen Wunsch erfüllt.
Ich bin sicher, auch Anja ist dir dankbar.
Aber wenn ich fort bin, wer wird dann über uns wachen?
All dieses Game, das macht mich fertig.
Jetzt schon, ey.
Wer sind sie?
Ähm...
Mein Name ist Eva, ich komme nur zufällig vorbei.
War sie ihre Frau?
Ja.
Ja, ihr Name war River.
Ich bin froh, dass sie River nicht übersetzt haben.
Ein außergewöhnlicher Name.
Das hätte nicht passieren müssen.
Hä?
Sie hätte es nicht tun müssen.
Aber...
Sie würden das nicht verstehen.
Ich verstehe es ja selbst nicht mal.
Was hat er denn da stehen?
Und wer ist Anja?
Notiz Anja erhalten, da gucken wir doch mal.
Anja.
Ich muss jetzt noch mal gucken, was das hier ist.
Was hat er denn hier stehen?
Ach, das ist der Grabstein.
Oder?
Das ist ihr Grabstein.
Jetzt erkenne ich das.
Das ist der Grabstein von River.
Wurde auch Zeit, dass du auftauchst.
Ich dachte schon, du wärst vor der Klippe gefallen.
Was hast du getrieben?
Den Ausblick genossen.
Was sonst?
Fortschritte gemacht?
Große Fortschritte.
Riesig.
Dinosaurier-artig
Tyrannosaurus-schreckt-artig
Ist das die Musik von dem Game?
Ja
Das Game hat übrigens einen Soundtrack
Den kann man sich kaufen
Wenn man den Entwickler unterstützen will
Ist super Soundtrack
Ziemlich einsam hier
Also es ist ein Leuchtturm, was erwartest du?
Wie auch immer, wir sehen uns auf der anderen Seite
Die Barriere
Musst du diesmal selbst durchbrennen
Viel Spaß
Eine kaputte Leuchtturmlampe
What?
Psschuu
Also wir sind noch nicht sonderlich weit in die Vergangenheit gekommen
Hat Max schon geweint
Ja und darum geht es denn, ne?
WBPD, darum geht es ja
Was zeigt die Mindestbewegung
Diese Minigames
Sind mir sowas von wurscht
Hat er schon gesagt, warum er zum Mond will?
Nein, hat er nicht
Und ich kann dir auch sagen, das wird noch bestimmt 1-2 Stunden dauern
Bis wir wissen, warum Johnny wirklich zum Mond will
Der Sibaro hier
Wieder mit absoluten Insider-Informationen am Start
Gehen wir weiter in die Vergangenheit
River lebt
Und Johnny ist jünger
Also sind wir ganze Stücke in die Vergangenheit weitergekommen
John, das kommt ganz gut hin
Und schon wieder jede Menge Hasen am Start
Wenn deine Operation bezahlt ist
Wird noch genug übrig sein
Also mach dir keine Sorgen
Notlüge
Und dann ist er wieder da
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich gerade wieder, man muss genauer darauf achten, wie River redet, weil ich hatte am Anfang, als ich das letzte Mal gespielt habe, weiß ich noch, habe ich erstmal nicht verstanden, was River für ein Problem hat oder was mit River los ist, habe ich beim ersten Mal durchspielen erst nicht wirklich kapiert.
Das heißt, ich kann euch nur mal so einen Tipp geben, guckt mal, wie River reagiert und wie sie so redet, dann wird das dann zwischenzeitlich klarer, was mit River los ist.
Man sieht schon, River ist sehr direkt, Notlüge, so nennt man das doch, oder nicht?
Äh, nein, ich bin sicher, wir können einfach, hör auf, ich mag es nicht, wenn du lügst.
Ich habe nachgerechnet, ich weiß, wie es aussieht.
Warum willst du mich gegen meinen Willen überzeugen?
Wir brauchen das Geld für deine Behandlung.
Behandlung, River?
Ich weiß, dass Anja dir viel bedeutet, aber das hier, das geht zu weit.
Ist Anja dieses Plüschtier?
Ich meine, sie, sie ist nicht einmal, weißt du, was mich glücklich macht, Johnny?
Was denn?
Weißt du es?
Frauenlogik.
Nun, ich weiß es.
Ich hoffe, du kannst mir dabei helfen.
River, wenn die Papiere für meine Behandlung ankommen, werde ich sie nicht unterzeichnen.
Was du mit unserem Geld machst, kannst du selbst entscheiden.
Ja.
Wer spoilert, fliegt raus, sage ich euch gleich.
Aber wenn du meinen Wunsch erfüllen möchtest, dann verwende das Geld, um das Haus fertig zu bauen.
Und dann möchte ich, dass du nach ihr siehst, jeden Tag, den du dort lebst.
Besuch sie, sprich mit ihr, tröste sie.
Wie auch immer Anja ist.
Ich will nicht, dass sie allein bleibt.
Und was ist mit dir?
Glücklich.
Ich werde glücklich sein, Johnny.
Jo.
Ich habe das hier gemacht.
Sag mir, was es ist.
Ein farbiger Hase.
Guten Job.
Hä?
Sag mir einfach, was es ist.
Es ist ein Hase, wie die anderen auch, die du gemacht hast.
Und weiter.
Naja, er ist aus Papier.
Der Körper ist gelb und der Rest ist blau.
Gut, weiter.
River.
Ich habe ein Lied geschrieben. Es ist für dich.
Okay.
Nun, möchtest du es hören?
Ja.
Hättest du nicht extra das Piano hochbringen müssen?
Nicht schlecht, Johnny. Nicht schlecht, das Ding, die Treppe hochzutragen.
Ich kann dich sehr gut hören, wenn die Tür offen ist.
Es heißt, Feel River.
Warum so klischeehaft?
Das ist nur ein Arbeitstitel.
Wenn man sich jetzt den Sound genau anhört, wird man merken, dass es eine andere Version von dem Lied ist, als am Anfang.
Wer ist diese Anja, von der beide gesprochen haben?
Und was wir auch gesehen haben, ist, dass River irgendwie...
...sehr direkt ist und kein Blatt vor den Mund nimmt.
Wer ist diese Anja, von der beide gesprochen haben?
Wenn sie so wichtig ist, hätten wir sie nicht in seinen späteren Erinnerungen sehen müssen?
Schätze, er hat sein Versprechen letztendlich doch nicht gehalten.
Also nach ihr zu gucken.
Es sei denn...
Was?
Egal.
Ist auch natürlich Frauenlogik.
Ja, was ist? Was? Sage ich dir nicht.
Ähm.
Aber vorher dreimal fragen, willst du es wissen?
Äh, hey, das ist doch dasselbe Lied, das die Kinder vorhin gespielt haben, oder?
Vermutlich hat er es ihnen beigebracht.
Ach, weißt du.
Das hier zieht nur meinen Testosteronspiegel runter.
Ich mach mich auf den Weg.
Ich habe schon meine Memo-Links.
Komm mit, oder willst du noch selber weiterschauen?
Naja gut, wir können ja hier nirgends wohin.
Gehen wir mit.
Gehen wir einfach.
Ähm, WWPD, also zur Story.
Johnny hat die beiden beauftragt.
Ihm seinen letzten Wunsch zu erfüllen, kurz bevor er stirbt.
Hey, schau mal, was wir hier haben.
Das unfertige Haus, wo wir vorhin drin waren.
Ich wette, sie haben die Klippen gesehen und gedacht, es wäre noch nicht gefährlich genug, solange keine Leute darauf wurden.
Johnny.
Dieser Bell.
Nick hat angerufen und mich hergebeten.
An Leute, die sich Johnny nicht mal so hundertprozentig erinnert, die sind halt so...
So grisselig.
Und manche sind auch komplett krass.
Ich habe dir eingelegte Oliven mitgebracht.
Die magst du am liebsten, stimmt's?
Da ist das Glas wieder.
Ich habe von River gehört.
Wird sie wieder gesund?
Ihre Krankheit wurde erst spät festgestellt.
Glücklicherweise ist sie behandelbar.
Aber die Kosten für die Behandlung...
Wir können uns nicht leisten, das Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabel.
Wir können kaum die Behandlungskosten bezahlen.
Ich bin froh, dass man ihr helfen kann.
Aber...
Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, wie viel dieser Ort ihr bedeutet.
Es wird ihr das Herz brechen.
Ich würde gern helfen.
Aber Ted und ich können es seit dem Finanzcrash selbst nur knapp über Wasser halten.
Was wirst du tun?
Ich werde ihr sagen, dass wir es schaffen können.
Dass wir uns beides leisten können.
Aber River ist nicht blöd, die hat es schon durchschaut.
Ich möchte nicht, dass sie eine Dummheit begeht.
Und sich nicht behandeln lässt.
Du solltest sie nicht anlügen, Johnny.
Du verstehst nicht, Isabel.
Wenn sie die Wahrheit herausfände, bin ich mir nicht sicher, was sie wählen würde.
Und...
Wenn sie entscheidet, dass ihr dieser Ort mehr bedeutet als ihr eigenes Leben, dann soll das eben so sein.
Naja.
Da muss ich sagen, da kann ich Isabel nicht zustimmen.
Was hast du von einem schönen Haus, wenn du selbst stirbst und das Haus...
Da hast du doch nichts von.
Es geht dir nicht um die Wahrheit.
Es geht dir nicht darum, was sie wirklich will.
Ihr Neurotypischen meint immer, ihr wüsstet, was das Beste für andere ist.
Das mag ich nicht.
Und ich hasse es, wenn du mich so nennst.
Eat sie.
Eat sie, Klepp.
Glaubst du denn, es geht nur um sie?
Was ist mit mir, Isabel?
Nach all den Jahren darf ich da nicht auch mal an mich denken.
Ich kann Johnny verstehen.
Johnny will nicht, dass seine Frau stirbt.
Hallo?
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
baue ich mein Haus fertig
oder sorge ich dafür, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt,
würde ich sagen, ich würde mich dafür entscheiden, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt.
Ich möchte nicht allein sein, Isabel.
Ich werde sie nicht sterben lassen.
Das ist anmaßend.
Pest, Pest.
Ja, Johnny, gebe ich dir voll recht.
Es wäre mir auch...
Was geht dir das an?
Wo willst du hin?
Ich werde dir etwas von der Klippe mitbringen.
Das wird sie ein wenig trösten.
Was du vorhast, wird davon nicht besser.
Nick wollte, dass ich dir das hier gebe.
Er sagt, das Lied heißt Everything's Alright.
Ich glaube, das ist das Lied, was von der Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies gesungen wird.
Ja.
Jetzt ernsthaft.
Gar nichts ist in Ordnung.
Johnny sagt quasi so innerlich gerade,
Piss dich, Alde.
Ah, mit dem Gurkenglas geht's weiter.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier untersuchen, was es hier noch so gibt.
Können wir in das Haus rein?
Ja.
Aber kann das Haus...
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Hier sehe ich jetzt nichts.
Gibt's ja nichts mehr drin.
Ist natürlich noch nichts fertig.
Wahrscheinlich sollen wir lieber Johnny hinterher...
Stelzauto.
Übrigens, wenn euch der Soundtrack gefällt,
könnt ihr ja mal gucken.
Den gibt's einzeln zu kaufen.
Und unterstützt natürlich auch den Entwickler.
Magst Spiel to the Moon?
Ja.
Feels Batman.
Noch fehlt es nicht Batman.
Eigentlich...
fehlt das Spiel...
Spiel nie Batman.
Sondern eher Cryman.
Ach, ich kann da gar nicht hoch hinlaufen.
Oh Leute, ich muss schon wieder aufs Klo.
The fuck?
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Aff...
Wieder da.
Tender vom Händen wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Ich kann auch einfach auf mein 3000 Euro High-End-Klo gehen, so oft ich will.
Easy clap.
Lösen wir wieder ein super anspruchsvolles, nerviges Minigame.
Memento aktivieren.
Weil es noch nicht oft genug auf dem Klo war, trinke ich jetzt erstmal was.
Ups.
Da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinklicken.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
200 IQ-Plays.
Ein High-Tech-Klo.
So richtig mit Stange zum Festhalten und Absenkautomat.
Klar, kennst du das doch.
Hast du das doch gesehen.
Ich hab's doch letztens gezeigt im Stream.
Eingelegte Oliven erhalten.
Memento aktivieren.
Jawoll.
Jetzt sind wir ein bisschen weiter in der Vergangenheit.
Der Nick sagt...
Also zieht ihr die Sache wirklich durch?
Hä?
Ja, die Bauarbeiten starten bereits in wenigen Monaten.
Wohlgemerkt, man muss da denken, es geht von hinten nach vorne.
Also das ist jetzt vor dem anderen.
War nicht ganz einfach.
Wir mussten Ratenzahlungen vereinbaren.
Aber jetzt, wo die Finanzierung steht, wird es schon klappen.
Wie wundervoll.
Euer eigenes Traumhaus und dann noch diese schönen...
Auf was?
Uuh, ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Und dann noch an diesem schönen Fleckchen Erde.
Ihr habt euch an dem Leuchtturm nicht weit von dort das Ja-Wort gegeben.
Stimmt's?
Ja.
Aber das ist es nicht allein.
River is hot.
Okay, ich gebe zu, das war es nicht dem Game angemessen, ja.
Wir und dieser Ort, das geht schon ganz lang zurück.
Tja, es ist schön, dass wir uns...
Auch mal etwas Erfreuliches zu erzählen haben.
Das Spiel ist so sad.
Ja, warte mal ab, das wird noch viel schlimmer.
Aber man scheint es ja zu kennen.
Lasst uns anschließen, auf euch beide.
Genau, auf uns.
Yeah.
Bin gleich wieder da, ich brauche etwas frische Luft.
Ich komme mit.
Tja, mein Freund.
Ist schon wieder ganz schön lange her.
Wohl wahr, wer hätte gedacht, dass die paar Kilometer mal zu einer solchen Hürde werden würden.
Diese River.
Immer noch so still, was?
Ach, sie ist eigentlich ganz gesprächig daheim.
Und wenn sie mit Isabelle zusammen ist.
Ich denke, sie ist einfach nicht gewohnt, dass du dabei bist.
Lul, jetzt bin ich der böse Junge, was?
Hey, also hast du River jetzt diese eine Sache erzählt, von früher?
Ja.
Wie hat sie es aufgenommen?
Insgesamt ganz gut.
Aber eine Sache gibt es, die mir noch zu schaffen macht.
Seit diesem Vorfall bastelt sie andauernd diese Selbstmordkarte.
Weltsam, Hasen aus Papier.
Origami-Hasen?
Ja, viele, jede Menge.
Ich habe auch früher mal Origami-Tiere gemacht, für meine Tochter, als sie noch klein war.
Was ist daran so schlimm?
Ich glaube nicht, dass man das vergleichen kann.
Nick.
Sie macht nichts anderes mehr, als diese Hasen zu basteln, Tag ein, Tag aus.
Unser Haus ist inzwischen voll mit den Dingern, bis oben hin.
Sagte Isabelle nicht, dass so etwas bei Menschen wie River nicht so gut ist?
Nichts Ungewöhnliches ist?
Bei Menschen wie River.
Schon, aber diesmal habe ich ein ungutes Gefühl.
Wenn ich sie darauf anspreche, antwortet sie mir nie.
Stattdessen bekommt sie diesen abweisenden Blick.
Fast als würde sie irgendwas von mir wollen.
Und das seltsame ist, ich habe das Gefühl, dass da wirklich etwas ist, das ich ihr schuldig bin.
Hast du mal Isabelle gefragt?
Ja, sie sagt, dass sie mit ihr gesprochen hat, aber auch nichts aus ihr rauskriegen konnte.
Tja.
Ja.
Ich bin sicher nicht der Fachmann hier, aber ich kann dir eins sagen.
Ich kenne dich seit der Mittelstufe.
Du hattest schon immer den Hang hier, um alles einen Kopf zu machen.
Du bildest dir da wahrscheinlich etwas ein.
Mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken.
Wenn jemand so einen Rat gibt, liegt meistens tatsächlich was im Wagen.
Aber gut, ich habe Zweifel, keine Gewissheit.
Wahrscheinlich hast du recht.
Wahrscheinlich, ich habe immer recht, Johnny.
Dr. Watts.
Moment mal.
Selbst er hat keine, also Johnny hat keine Ahnung, was mit diesen Hasen los war.
Vergiss die dummen Hasen, wir haben ganz andere Probleme.
Wir sind hier in einer abgegrenzten Erinnerung und es gibt keinerlei Momentos.
Keine Panik.
Wir können wahrscheinlich eins von ihm selbst bekommen.
What?
Sieh zu und lerne.
Ich muss nur kurz diesem Wirt einen Besuch abstatten.
Dem da?
Hallo, was darf's sein?
Was geht?
Haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Na, das ist ja das, was man immer...
Ne?
Also in...
...der Kneipe, so.
Flo 96 ist neu hier, sagt Hallo.
Oh, das ist ein neues Feature?
Hallo, Flo 96.
Das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man, wenn man das erste Mal im Chat ist, jetzt irgendeine Nachricht schreiben kann.
Nice.
Haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Klar doch, zahlen Sie bar oder mit Karte.
Check.
Hm, tut mir leid.
Checks nehmen wir nicht.
Tja, dann schreiben Sie es einfach auf meinen Deckel.
Moment, soll das heißen, Sie haben kein Geld?
Dich werde ich sowas von resetten.
Hallo, was darf's sein?
Ähm, Little Samson, wo spielt das Game?
Also, wenn ich im Land Kontinent...
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich...
Das spielt überhaupt keine Rolle.
Ich würde mal sagen, irgendwo in Europa vielleicht?
So Frankreich oder so?
Keine Ahnung.
Tagchen, haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Klar doch, zahlen Sie bar oder mit Karte.
Schreiben Sie auf meinen Deckel.
Heute mache ich richtig einen drauf.
Oho, geht klar, der Herr.
Hier sind Ihre eingelegten Oliven.
Ich mache auch immer mit eingelegten Oliven einen drauf.
Danke, Kumpel.
Da wird heute jemand eine Menge Trinkgeld einstreichen.
Danke, der Herr.
Ja, wenn der müsste.
Du kannst ein Arsch sein, Niel.
Ach, merk dich locker.
Alde.
Jetzt mache ich das mit eingelegten Oliven.
Ich setze mich jetzt zu Johnny und rede mit ihm über eingelegte Oliven.
Na nun, sehen meine getrübten Augen da etwa ein Gläschen eingelegte Oliven?
So ist es.
Sie wissen auch eine gute Olive zu schätzen.
Allerdings, ich habe mir gerade eben ein frisches Glas bestellt.
Was für ein Zufall.
Darf ich?
Natürlich, setzen Sie sich.
Wir kippen gemeinsam ein Gläschen eingelegte Oliven.
Oh ja, das klingt doch nach einem Plan.
Eva, Geschmackssimulation aussetzen, jetzt.
Ich habe keine Lust.
Nein.
Dafür wirst du noch was.
Dafür wirst du noch bezahlen.
Und so sind wir zu unserem ersten Toaster gekommen.
Haha.
Lul.
Ux.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Mich nimmt nur das Geschmackserlebnis dieser eingelegten Oliven total gefangen.
Einfach wundervoll, nicht wahr?
Oh ja, man kann sich kaum vorstellen, dass irgendjemand diesen Dinger ekelerregend finden könnte.
Lassen Sie sich Zeit.
Wir haben ja nur zwei volle Gläser.
Also habe ich gesagt, hey, das ist...
Also habe ich...
Ist das Inscope oder was ist hier los?
Also habe ich gesagt, hey, ist das nicht in Ordnung?
Und Sie haben mir recht gegeben.
Johnny labert.
Und wissen Sie, was noch an unserer Gesellschaft nicht stimmt?
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Ich habe sogar dabei, wieso...
Darf ich mal sehen?
Hm, na gut.
Bitte sehr.
Das ist das Klavierstück?
Und anhalten.
Endlich.
Herr im Wirbel.
Wie waren die Oliven, Neil?
Halt die Klappe.
Piss dich, Alde.
Momento gefunden.
Fang bloß nicht wieder an.
Mach dir keine Sorgen.
Siehst du, alles nach Vorschrift.
Der Typ hat teilweise so den übertriebenen Cringe-Dialog, ey.
Das lese ich jetzt nicht vor.
Ernsthaft, Neil.
Ich versuche gerade, mich in die Situation reinzuversetzen und du versaust die Stimmung.
Das war es wert.
Okay.
Machen wir wieder ein ganz tolles Minigame.
Übrigens, ich hatte...
Als ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe, hatte ich keinen Bock auf die Minigames.
Da habe ich einfach immer wild rumgeklickt, bis sie gelöst waren.
Moment, hä?
Ey.
What?
Ach so.
Easy clap.
Hallo, hier wird alles gelesen.
Ja, ja.
Ganz bestimmt.
Aktivieren.
Wir sind wieder am Leuchtturm.
Und sie sind eine ganze Ecke jünger wieder.
Also, wir sind ziemlich schnell gerade.
Das Spiel ist ja auch nicht so ultralang.
Das ist eher...
Ist halt einfach interaktive Geschichte als Game.
Heiliges Känguru.
Du bist kein Australier.
Ja, und?
Wir sind hier ungefähr 20 Milliarden Nanometer über Normal-Nullen.
Und stehen auf einem verdammten Lampenmast.
Spring einfach runter.
Es ist ja nicht so, als könntest du dich hier verletzen.
Machst du Witze?
Das ist wie Bungee-Jumping ohne Seil.
Alter, das ist so ein Schwätzer, der Typ.
Oben bleiben geht nicht.
Runter kommen auch nicht.
Mann, wie ich hasse es, wenn...
Was?
Reading-Skills, lol.
Oben bleiben geht nicht.
Runter kommen auch nicht.
Mann, wie ich es hasse, wenn das passiert.
Ich schwöre dir, wenn dieser Ort...
Eva.
What the fuck?
War ich...
Das haben sie echt schön gemacht hier.
Für ein RPG-Maker-Spiel.
River.
Warum hat man sie wohl verlassen?
Ich nehme an,
sie hat sie nicht verlassen.
Ich nehme an, sie hat sie nicht verlassen.
Sie wurde einfach nicht mehr gebraucht.
Nicht mehr gebraucht?
Für Schiffe, meine ich.
Du weißt ja, wie das heutzutage ist,
mit GPS und all dem Kram.
Hör mal, River.
Dieser Ort bedeutet mir sehr viel
und ich habe nachgedacht.
Im Moment läuft doch alles recht gut für uns.
Und wenn wir sparen ein paar Jahre lang,
dann können wir hier oben ein Haus bauen.
Wir werden uns einschränken müssen,
aber ich...
Wir könnten sie vom Fenster aus sehen.
Morgens, abends, wir wären immer in ihrer Nähe.
Und?
Wir könnten jederzeit hierher gehen.
Sie wäre nie mehr allein, John.
Ich könnte jeden Tag auf sie aufpassen.
Ja, das werden wir.
Ich gönne es ihr.
Das meinst du nicht ernst?
Du weißt, was passieren wird, oder?
Es ist, als würde man einem Zug
bei einem Gleisen zusehen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Da hat er recht.
Das Ende ist nicht wichtiger,
als irgendeiner der Momente, die zu ihm führen.
Was zählt, ist, dass die beiden hier und jetzt glücklich sind.
Lass uns gehen.
Ich kann es an der Stelle nur noch mal sagen,
wenn ich mir das hier so angucke.
Ich kann einfach...
Ich sage jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen
billigen 2D-Sprites
so viel mehr Gefühl abnehmen
und Emotionen abnehmen,
als ich das in einem 3D-Model kann.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da mein Problem ist
in der Richtung,
aber ist bei mir halt so.
Moment mal.
Sie haben den Leuchtturm Anja genannt, oder nicht?
Ich glaube schon.
Dann hat diese River
auf medizinische Versorgung verzichtet
wegen einem Leuchtturm?
Ist das nicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben?
Also, ich habe in diesem Beruf
schon Merkwürdigeres erlebt.
Ja, ich auch,
aber ich gewöhne mich einfach nicht daran.
Es kann dir ohnehin egal sein.
Sie ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Sie ist schließlich nicht unsere Patientin.
Notiz Anja erhalten.
Okay, Anja ist tatsächlich
der Leuchtturm.
Und wegen Anja wollte sich River nicht operieren lassen.
Die ist halt
hart drauf.
Aber das Schöne ist,
es ergibt alles wunderbar Sinn in dem Game.
Und wir werden auch gleich noch
erfahren, warum.
Nee, da müssen wir nicht hinterher.
Hallo, Fenris Blue.
Die Musik ist auch wirklich sehr stimmungsvoll,
Max Punch.
Ja, ist sie.
Soundtrack ist echt gut.
Eines der besten Game-Soundtracks,
wo Game zu Game zu Musik ist wirklich super.
Ich glaube, wir sollen hier runter.
Kamen wir hier runter auf die Straße?
Nee.
Ah, ein Hase.
Hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen,
hätte ich da nicht zufällig draufgeklickt.
Neil, bitte keine Cringe-Dialoge mehr.
Vorbereiten.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich hab mich aufgepasst.
Fuck.
Äh.
Ich bin überfordert von, von Minigames.
Moment.
Wie, wie fung...
Okay.
Okay, mal, mal langsam.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ah.
Ich bin nicht mehr verwirrt.
900 IQ-Plays.
Advanced Brain.
Jetzt ist Johnny aber nochmal eine ganze Ecke jünger, oder?
Ja.
Johnny ist jetzt, keine Ahnung, 40?
River?
Wo steckt River?
Der Hase?
Gibt's sonst nix zum angucken?
Wo ist River?
Wo ist Johnny?
Das ist jetzt definitiv nicht ihr Haus.
Das ist jetzt ein altes, anderes Haus.
Ein alter Flügel.
Wie zu hören haben sie das Ding die Treppe raufbekommen?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich wette, das wäre ein Klacks für die...
TARDIS.
Für was?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Da mir steht fest, Pianos zu bewegen ist für jeden ein Albtraum.
Das würde wahrscheinlich...
...eine komplette Episode lang dauern, das dorthin zu bekommen.
Was ist TARDIS?
Die würde ich mir sogar anschauen.
Doctor Who.
Äh, hab ich nicht geguckt, deswegen checke ich das wahrscheinlich nicht.
TARDIS, kurz für Redarts.
Nein, das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ok, Doctor Who, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich nie geguckt.
Kann ich alles verstehen.
Damit kann man durch Raum und Zeit...
Ach, sind das die Telefonzellen aus Doctor Who?
Was sind die Telefonzellen?
Ahhhh.
Doch, das habe ich mal irgendwo gelesen.
Jede Menge Papierhasen wieder.
John, Johnny, du bist so früh aus dem Haus gegangen, um zum Friseur zu gehen.
Der Fristmeister.
Wusste gar nicht, dass er hier mitspielt.
Was machst du da?
Hasen.
River ist immer sehr direkt.
Hast du den Hasen gesehen, den ich für dich dagelassen habe?
Ja.
Erzähl mir etwas über ihn.
Ok, dieses Spiel macht River wohl öfters.
Hä?
Beschreib ihn.
River will...
Ähm, er war gelb.
River will Johnny mit diesen Hasen irgendwas sagen.
So wie es für mich aussieht.
Und Johnny checkt es nicht.
Weil River fragt ihn jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal, jetzt im Abstand von ein paar Jahren,
ähm, was er zu diesem Hasen sagt.
Und Johnny checkt es irgendwie nicht.
Ähm, er war gelb.
Und weiter?
Ein bisschen pummelig.
Ja.
Und?
Na ja.
Es ist eben ein Papierhase.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich sonst über ihn sagen soll.
Ha.
Du benimmst dich merkwürdig, River.
River benimmt sich schon die ganze Zeit merkwürdig.
Glaubst du sie ist
Glaubst du das
Jetzt spuckt es aus Jungs
Vielleicht wer weiß
Leider ist das Spiel schon so alt
Ja das heißt
Einige von euch haben es wahrscheinlich sogar schon gespielt
Deswegen frage ich jetzt nicht
Was meint ihr denn was ist mit River los
Und nicht mit Carsten
Mit River
Weil ich finde wenn man aufgepasst hat
Das merke ich jetzt beim zweiten mal spielen
Kommt man eigentlich drauf
Was mit River los ist
Zumal das Isabelle
Vorhin auch noch quasi indirekt gesagt hat
Vielleicht wer weiß
Aber wie du schon sagtest
Sie ist nicht unsere Patientin
Lass uns die Dinge zu Ende bringen
Für die wir auch bezahlt werden
Also was wir jetzt aktuell über River wissen
Ist sie ist relativ direkt
Sie ist nicht sonderlich
Einfühlsam und macht komische
Dinger und versucht Johnny irgendwas
Mitzuteilen was er nicht
Versteht aber was für sie
Relativ klar ist
Und er sieht es einfach nicht
Ah ok hier geht es weiter
Das ist jetzt der Tag
An dem sie damit anfängt
Also hier
Hasen zu falten
Guck mal was Johnny dazu zu sagen hat
Nichts
Ein Eimer
Viele lange orangefarbene Haarsträhnen
Ähm habe ich irgendwo was vergessen
Anzuklicken
Ich glaube ich habe irgendwo was vergessen
Hm
Ne oben
Dann habe ich oben was vergessen
Hier das habe ich vergessen
Ein gelber Papierhase
Oh Gott nicht schon wieder
Ah das hätten wir am Anfang sehen sollen
Haben wir aber nicht
Das ist der dicke Papierhase von dem sie unten gesprochen haben
Wir haben nicht richtig geguckt
Wir sind Point and Click Noobs
Nein da habe ich nicht drauf geklickt
Sagen die noch was sie hat
Ja
Anverstanden
Man versteht was mit River los
Man versteht in dem Game prinzipiell alles was passiert am Ende
Woran man sieht wie gut das Game geschrieben ist
Ok nein
Neil oder wie auch immer man nicht ausspricht
Keine cringe Dialoge bitte
Nein diesmal nicht
Ok weiter
Optimale Anzahl 3
Lol 3
Ähm
Max fast richtig
Sebarro ich fürchte das kommt noch
Zwei
Never Entry
Ich weiß ja die Hälfte von dem Game auch nicht mehr.
Plus so ein paar Schlüsselsachen noch.
Und viele Sachen fallen mir jetzt auch zum ersten Mal so richtig auf.
Gucken wir, dass wir nichts vergessen.
Bei Nähe gibt es nichts.
Einfach laufen, wo gut ist.
Sibaro, nicht spoilern.
Aber das würdest du eh nicht machen.
Muss ich dir nicht sagen.
So, wo sind sie?
Oder wo ist was?
Hier ist nichts.
Wir sind genau falsch gelaufen.
Wir müssen auf die andere Seite.
Also ich muss echt sagen, für ein RPG-Maker-Spiel ist hier wirklich sehr viel Liebe reingeflossen.
Und Details.
Das ist die Stelle, an der früher das Haus stand, oder?
Das Haus, das niemals hätte sein dürfen.
Allerdings kommt es erst ein paar Jahre später.
Mal ehrlich, was finden die Leute an ungewöhnlichen, hohen und gefährlichen Plätzen denn so faszinierend?
Höhenangst.
Stimmt, Neil hat Höhenangst.
Stimmt, fällt mir wieder ein.
Nein, oder Neil, oder nein, wie auch immer, man hat Höhenangst.
Das kommt in Finding Paradise noch öfters mal.
Mal nebenbei, was ist denn ein RPG-Maker?
Das ist ein Spiele-Engine quasi.
Für halt so 2D-Games.
Also quasi sowas wie Unity plus viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel einfacher und für 2D.
Wo geht's denn lang?
Genau, hier stand das Haus früher.
Was heißt früher?
Später.
Später wird das Haus hier mal stehen.
Was?
Äh, wisst ihr was, Leute, wir speichern mal.
Das kann nicht schaden.
Der Rucksack!
Und sie sind auch mal eine Ecke jünger.
Deswegen hast du mich damals angesprochen, Johnny?
Ja.
Wie sieht es jetzt aus?
Schätze, es gehört dazu.
Es gehört dazu?
Nicht, dass es hier gleich jetzt FSK 18 wird?
Hör mal, das ist lang her.
Es spielt eigentlich keine Rolle mehr, aber ITZY, Isabel, meinte, ich sollte dir besser die Wahrheit sagen.
Ich hätte unser erstes Treffen nicht so vermasseln sollen.
Unsere Richte mit Augenkontakt hat's River auch nicht, das haben sie echt gut gemacht.
Was ist das? Ein Hacky-Sack.
Kannst du ihn bis zu Anja werfen?
Okay, Anja ist wirklich der Leuchtturm.
Keine Ahnung, soll ich das probieren?
Würdest du?
Klar.
Ja, Johnny will River beeindrucken.
Natürlich will er.
River, bist du verrückt? Geh weg!
Huch.
Ich glaube, diese Erinnerung ist nicht so weit von der letzten entfernt.
Was glaubst du, besteht da ein Zusammenhang?
Wahrscheinlich.
Was macht was mit dem Rucksack los?
Memento gefunden.
Wieso hat sie sich die Haare abgeschnitten?
Ich mag lange Haare.
Das Schöne ist, dass ich das Game wirklich vor drei Jahren oder irgendwie so gespielt habe.
Also, sprich, ich weiß eigentlich bis auf ein paar Sachen gar nichts mehr zu die wichtigen Sachen.
Okay, Minigame.
Minigame-Skills.
Äh.
Easy.
Easy-Clap.
Schreckt-Minigame.
Aktivieren.
Isabelle.
Die Störung wirkt sich bei jedem anders aus, John.
Nur weil wir beide daran leiden, sind wir nicht dieselbe Person.
Nein.
Anfangs war alles noch ganz in Ordnung.
Aber jetzt ist sie nur noch distanzierter als vorher.
Selbst wenn wir im selben Zimmer sind, sie ist nie wirklich da.
Das geht mir langsam an die Substanz.
Ah, Johnny, das kann ich verstehen.
Was ist schlimmer, als wenn du fragst, was stimmt nicht?
Wenn offensichtlich was nicht stimmt.
Und dann kriegt man als Antwort nichts.
Dann muss man ein bisschen weiterfragen. Jetzt erzähl doch mal, was ist denn los?
Nein, nein, ist nix.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das aushalten soll.
Nun ja, ich kann nicht für sie sprechen, aber viele von uns wollen nicht alleine sein.
Von uns.
Eine ganz andere Frage ist aber, ob man das auch zeigen kann.
Es könnte der Grund sein, warum River Hasen bastelt.
Dass sie sich damit schwer tut, heißt noch nicht, dass sie keine Gefühle hat.
Sie ist schließlich immer noch da, oder?
Manchmal musst du dir einfach den Glauben bewahren, dass du ihr wichtig bist.
Es ist nicht leicht, sich das zu sagen, jeden Tag aufs Neue.
Ich weiß.
Sag mal, warum wirkst du eigentlich so normal, Isabelle?
Easy ist eine grausame Abkürzung für Isabelle.
Ich meine, habt ihr nicht die gleiche?
Ist das eine Sache?
Nun ja, bei mir wurde es festgestellt, als ich noch sehr jung war.
Es ist mühsam, aber nicht unmöglich, sich dann eine Maske sozialer Normen systematisch anzueignen.
Jetzt kommen wir der Sache näher, was River eigentlich hat.
Weißt du, ich beneide River, ebenso wie ich sie bemitleide.
Ich bin Schauspielerin geworden, weil ich mein Leben lang eine sein musste.
Nicht nur auf der Bühne, sondern auch sonst immer.
Nein, Little Samsung, es geht immer nur rückwärts.
Ich bin so gut darin geworden, weil ich keine andere Wahl hatte.
Nur so kann ich normal sein.
Aber River hat das nie versucht.
Sie blieb einer Außenseit drin und hat nie etwas dagegen getan.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es nicht konnte oder nicht wollte, ob sie tapfer oder feige war.
Es gibt Tage, an denen ich die ganze Verstellerei einfach nicht mehr aushalten kann.
Und dann merke ich, es ist zu spät.
Die Isabelle, die die Leute kannten, ist nur eine Show.
Und mein wahres Ich ist zu einer Fremden geworden.
Ich glaube, letztlich beneide ich River.
Jetzt kommen wir der Sache wirklich langsam näher, was River hat.
Ich glaube, es wird nie genau ausgesprochen, aber man kommt drauf.
Und wenn nicht, sage ich es euch nochmal, dass man es auch versteht.
Ich habe noch nie eine Frau mit solchen Problemen getroffen.
Dann hast du wohl bisher noch keine einzige Frau getroffen, Neil.
Das hier geht uns nichts an.
Komm.
Also, ich denke, an der Stelle kann ich verraten, was River hat, weil man hat es eigentlich schon komplett erfahren.
Ja, Fenris Blue. Fenris Blue hat es erkannt.
Also, sie hat keine gespaltene Persönlichkeit.
Sie ist Autist.
Fenris Blue hat es erkannt.
Sie hat Asperger.
River.
Das wird, glaube ich, nie in dem Game wirklich genauso gesagt, aber es ist ziemlich offensichtlich.
Die Welt wäre ein schöner Ort, wenn sich die Leute Gesichter besser merken würden.
Ja, sprich, Leute, die in der Erinnerung egal sind, sind halt einfach grau.
Irgendwas Neues heute?
Nein.
Was liest du da?
Das Kaisers neue Kleider.
Deswegen hat es Johnny auch später in seiner Wohnung liegen gehabt.
Ich habe es geliebt, als ich klein war.
Und tust du es noch?
Natürlich.
Nur aus anderen Gründen.
Als ich ein Kind war, stand ich total auf die Animorph-Serie.
Ja gut, Johnny war ja auch ein normales Kind.
Weiß ich.
Deine Mutter hat dir ein Animorphs-Buch zu unserer Hochzeit geschenkt.
Ja, das war ein ganz schön merkwürdiges Geschenk.
Ich war als Kind wohl ziemlich besessen von dieser Serie.
Ich habe als Kind, muss ich jetzt gerade mal der Zeit sagen, was ich als Kind geil fand,
war Super Teenage Mutant Ninja Hero Turtles.
Beste Serie.
Turtles, beste Serie.
Ja, und wie Meister Splinter damals schon gesagt hat,
manchmal ist Rückzug die bessere Verteidigung.
Nee, oder?
Irgendwie so.
Das fand ich geil damals.
Warum hast du sie seitdem nicht wieder gelesen?
Ich habe die Bücher gesehen.
Sie verstauben in der Garage.
Naja, ich bin herausgewachsen, schätze ich.
Gut, Johnny ist jetzt auch ungefähr, keine Ahnung, 35.
Da liest man vielleicht eher nicht mehr Animorphs.
Die Animorph-Serie.
Es sind eben Kinderbücher.
Was ist falsch daran, Kinderbücher zu lesen?
Johnny.
Was ist falsch an Kinderbüchern zu lesen?
Sie spenden Trost.
Schon möglich.
Ich werde mir wohl dieses hier kaufen.
Ich liebe mich und du liebst dich.
Wir lieben uns ganz fürchterlich.
Grandioser Buchtitel.
Hey River, das hier ist gar nicht mal so schmalzig.
River?
Gut, schon wieder weg.
Social Heulen, was ist das?
Das wirst du gleich noch sehen.
Und was ist mit Davids?
Der ist mein Lieblingscharakter.
John, ähm, keine Ahnung.
Worüber redet ihr?
Animorphs, kennen Sie das?
Nein.
Ja, natürlich kennt Neil Animorphs, was sonst?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist, aber es hört sich an wie irgendwie sowas wie Turtles, was ich früher geguckt habe.
Wirklich?
Mehr oder weniger.
Oh, wissen Sie, in welches Tier sich David verwandelt?
Ähm...
Was weiß ich, in welches Tier sich David verwandelt?
In eine A-weise.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wo ist denn das S?
Ah, mehr geht nicht, fuck.
Das klingt nicht richtig.
Keine Sorge, ich finde es schon noch heraus.
Ah, in eine Cobra verwandelt er sich, okay.
Du hättest doch einfach googeln können.
Okay, das spielt nicht so lange in der Vergangenheit.
Cobra, in eine Cobra verwandelt er sich.
Okay, das muss man jetzt...
Ja, ich weiß es.
In eine...
Cobra.
Ha, richtig.
Eine Cobra.
Beatport.
Wir spielen To The Moon.
Das geht hier ab.
Ich wünschte wirklich, sie hätten noch die alten Covers statt diese Ölen-Umschläge.
Ist wirklich cool.
So, jetzt haben wir alle Momentos zusammen.
Jetzt können wir eigentlich...
weitermachen.
Pschu.
Zumindest wissen wir jetzt, dass River Autist ist.
Autistin.
Wir respektieren ja Frauen.
Kann man nicht so rumdrehen, das Ganze?
Das ist ja doof.
Moment, man kann nicht so rumdrehen, ne?
Oh Gott, ich bin schlecht.
Schlecht in diesen komischen Puzzeln.
Ja, aber spielt ihr das ernsthaft?
Sieht nicht aus wie ein typisches Max-Game.
Man sollte sich nicht von der Optik eines Games so sehr darauf festlegen, was das für ein Game ist.
To The Moon ist eines der besten...
Wie nennt man das?
Es ist ja kein Spiel in dem Sinn.
Quasi...
Buch in Spiel.
In der Form, was ich je gespielt hab.
Aktivieren.
Visual Novels, genau.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Und vor allem eines der Spiele mit dem besten Soundtrack überhaupt.
So, jetzt dürfte Johnny so ein paar und zwanzig sein, würde ich sagen.
Och, es gehen schon alle.
Ich bin doch gerade erst da.
Scheint hier bei Partys häufiger so zu passieren.
Ach komm.
Heb dir deine kindischen Scherze für Leute ohne Selbstbewusstsein auf.
Guck mal, da ist wieder das Olivenglas und das Buch.
Ich sehe.
Le Fromage.
Was?
Oh, es ist französisch.
Aber wo ist die Maus?
Neil, manchmal check ich deine Witze nicht.
Du redest ja immer viel Plötzchen, aber das ist bisher das Highlight des Abends.
Willst du nicht eher sagen, dass ich nur Käse rede?
Lol.
Wo sind wir hier denn jetzt?
Irgendwo im Wald.
Warum stehen im Wald so viele Leute, mit denen ich nix anfangen kann?
Wo sind die hier denn überhaupt alle?
Was machen die hier?
Oh.
Okay, geht's nicht weiter.
Ah, Patrick, siehste.
Jetzt hab ich den Witz auch kapiert.
Ich brauch halt, ich bin, wie gesagt, ich bin ja schon 33.
Das braucht's manchmal einfach ein bisschen länger, weißt du?
Kein Big Brain.
Wir kommen echt gut voran in dem Game.
Ich glaub, das letzte Mal hab ich länger gebraucht.
Ich hab auch alles angeguckt und so.
Jetzt sind sie mal eine ganze Ecke, Junge.
Paar und 20, ich würd mal sagen, kurz nach ihrer Hochzeit, hä?
Okay, man kann nicht mit ihnen reden.
John, fühlt es sich anders an?
Ich mein, jetzt?
Jetzt, wo wir die Ringe tragen?
Nein.
River ist da immer sehr direkt.
Warum, fühlst du dich anders?
Also eigentlich, ja, ich denk schon.
Wie fühlt es sich an?
Es ist einfach anders.
Wahrscheinlich nur die Verantwortung.
Verantwortung?
Hä?
Magst du den Namen Anja?
Jetzt wissen wir, warum der Leuchtturm so heißt.
Möchtest du sie Anja nennen?
Ich verstehe.
Anja ist ein schöner Name.
Nachdem wir jetzt wissen, dass River Autist ist, ergibt das auch viel mehr Sinn,
warum sie manchmal so Sachen erzählt, die vielleicht jetzt erstmal ein bisschen merkwürdig klingen.
Hey, komm mal her.
Sebaro sagt, River ist so niedlich.
Ja, find ich auch.
Oh, das ist keine gute Idee.
Ich werde stolpern und fallen.
Keine Sorge, folge einfach meinen Schritten.
Ach ja.
Huch, Autsch, mein Hintern.
Ich glaube, du bist mir auf den Fuß gedrehten.
Äh, ups.
Komm, versuchen wir es nochmal.
Jetzt ist ihre Hochzeit.
Versprichst du sie zu lieben, zu ehren, in guten wie in schlechten Tagen, bis dass der Tod euch scheidet?
Das tue ich.
Und möchtest du diesen Mann, der nun vor dir steht, Johnny Wiles, zu deinem Ehemann nehmen?
Versprichst du ihn zu lieben, zu ehren, in guten wie in schlechten Tagen, bis dass der Tod euch scheidet?
Ja.
Kraft meines Amtes erkläre ich euch hiermit zum Mann und Frau.
Meine Damen und Herren, vor Ihnen stehen Mr. und Mrs. Wiles.
Ach, die Hochzeit.
Äh, ja, was dachtest du denn, was das wird?
Ihr habt sich so mit Hochzeiten, das ist alles.
Flüssigkeiten sammeln sich in beiden Augen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so sentimental sein kannst, Nile.
Oh, sag dich Augen, äh, ich mein Mund.
Und da sammeln sich nicht nur Flüssigkeiten, sondern auch Festes.
Das ist ein reizender Gedanke, Nile, das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Komm, lass uns einen Weg hier rausfinden.
All diese Glückseligkeit ist selbst für mich zu viel, ne?
Nein, ich mag es einfach nicht, anderen dabei zuzuschauen, wie sie Fehler begehen.
Frau Doktor, wo bleibt...
...denn ihr Augenblick...
Augenblick, was?
Wo bleibt...
...ihr der Augenblick zählt?
So, können wir hier noch irgendwas einsammeln?
Ne, uns fehlt noch ein...
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas vergessen?
Uns fehlen noch zwei.
Ach, hier unten geht's weiter.
Aus Gurkenglas.
Oh, ich sollte mal schauen, wie es meiner Tante geht.
Alles klar, Mama.
Sag ihr, dass ich mich freue, dass sie gekommen ist.
Mach ich.
Übrigens, mal ein Hinweis drauf.
Wenn...
...wenn das Mama von Johnny ist...
...ist das Mama von Johnny?
Dafür ist sie aber ganz schön ver...
...verschwommen, oder?
Ich meine, seine Mutter erinnert man sich normalerweise.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich, Johnny.
Der Nick ist wieder am Start.
Joey.
Ach, so hieß mein Großvater.
Ach, Moment.
Hat...
...hat...
...hat sie ihn gerade Johnny oder Joey genannt?
Hm...
Er ist gestorben, bevor ich geboren wurde.
Ja.
Sie hat...
... Whiteinned?!
Ja, man bekommt ja introducing.
...
Oh.
Ah, Scheiß.
Ich erinnere mich wieder, was er mit Joey auf sich hat.
Oh je.
Verlutnnng.
Nick.
Wie kommt es, dass du mir nie davon erzählt hast?
Weil ich besser finde, wenn du mich John nennst.
Johnny.
Nicht noch eine von diesen Großeltern-Kindheit...
Großeltern-Kindheiten.
Wieso?
Was hast du dagegen?
Ich meine, über deinen Großvater erzählst du immer eine ganze Menge.
Was? Stimmt doch gar nicht.
Ganz wie du meinst.
Joey erhalten.
Tja, wer ist Joey?
Joies Spitzname nach seinem Großvater.
Ich erinnere mich, dass das nicht so einfach war.
So, habe ich jetzt irgendwo was vergessen?
Wo geht es denn weiter?
Äh.
Heute ist doch irgendwas aufgefallen, wo es weiter geht?
Ah, hier unten können wir nochmal gucken.
Ich bin so stolz auf Joey.
Warum Joey?
Okay, was habe ich denn vergessen?
Und vor allem, wo ist das Momento, wo es weiter geht?
Hier kann man ja nichts anklicken.
Ach, hier unten geht es weiter.
Was ist da los?
Da kann man nichts mehr machen, River.
Ich bin sicher, es war keine Absicht.
Komm schon, wir kommen zu spät.
Warte mal.
Ist das ein Hase?
Ach ja, weil eben jemand gesagt hat im Chat, er hat das Gefühl, dass die Erinnerungen vorwärts und rückwärts gehen.
Also, die Szenen, die gehen immer nur von vorne nach hinten, also von hinten nach vorne, allerdings in so einer Szene, je nachdem, wo man hingeht, können die Ereignisse schon in unterschiedlicher Reihenfolge sein.
Also, das ist jetzt ja eindeutig vor ihrer Hochzeit, weil sie sind ja gerade auf dem Weg zur Hochzeit.
Warte mal, ist das ein Hase?
Was meinst du, ist das der Ursprung der ganzen Papierhasen?
Warum sollte sie sich an der Sache mit dem überfahrenen Tier dermaßen festbeißen?
Vor allem erst so viele.
Ich bin ja schon ein paar Jahre danach.
Was fragst du mich?
Du bist hier die Frau.
Davon werde ich erst überzeugt sein, wenn du dich traust, einen Banshee-Sprung ohne Seil zu machen.
Toter Hase.
Hat das irgendwas damit zu tun?
Ein komisches Minigame?
Äh, what?
Easy.
So, jetzt...
Wir kommen immer mehr in die Jugend von Johnny.
Der Typ, ey.
Du weißt, dass es eine fantastische Hochzeit war, wenn das Momento eine Überraschung...
...überfahrenes Tier ist.
Hey.
Vielleicht sah sie das als eine Art Metapher für die schreckliche Ehe.
Und dann Jahre später fing sie an, Hasen zu falten, weil sie sich daran erinnerte, wie sehr es hier...
Was?
Wie sehr das hier zum Himmel stank.
Ja, nein, fantasiert ihr nichts zusammen.
Oder, was weiß ich, irgendwas ähnlich Wichtigturisches.
Coole.
Cool Story, Bro.
Da ist der Hase.
Armes Ding.
Was ist das eigentlich heute für...
Was ist das heute für ein Tag mit den ganzen...
...überfahrenen Tieren?
Schau mich nicht so an.
Es riecht nach Bauernhof hier.
Und nach überfahrenen Tieren.
Lass uns den Geruchssimulator deaktivieren und schleunigst von dir verschwinden.
Geht's hier eigentlich rein?
Splatter.
What?
Ein krass animiertes Horse.
Da kann Billy Ohr einpacken.
Lass es sein.
Was genau soll ich sein lassen?
Das weißt du genau.
Ich soll es sein lassen, nicht von diesem Pferd...
Was?
Nicht auf diesem Pferd.
Nicht auf diesem Pferd zu reiten.
Wie alt bist du?
Fünf?
Zwölf, by the way.
Okay, ich werde auf keinen Fall auf diesem Pferd reiten.
Yeah.
Auf geht's.
Hör auf, Zeit zu verschwenden, Nile.
Fuck.
Das ist nicht gut.
Nun mach was.
Steh nicht blöd rum.
Verdammt, das stand nicht in meiner Stellenbeschreibung.
Was sagt die Notiz zu Dr. Nile?
Äh, Dr. Watts.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt hier gelandet?
Auf dem Bauernhof.
Ist aber nix.
Ist wirklich.
Und die Erinnerungen hören hier halt auch auf.
River!
Und Johnny.
Jetzt würde ich mal sagen, so, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre oder so.
Soll ich auf das Pferd drauf und mit rein?
Ne.
Moment.
Was ist hier denn?
Geht's jetzt hier weiter oder nicht?
Äh, hallo?
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ich glaub, ich hab irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Ja.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass ich hier so lang rumre...
äh, rumlaufen muss.
Vor allem in diesem, in diesem Schneckentempo.
Ja, und hier ist die Erinnerung fertig.
Hä?
Ähm.
Hier ist die Straße wieder.
Ich muss doch auf das Pferd drauf, oder?
Also, ich, ich kann mich da noch dunkel dran erinnern,
aber man muss die hier ins Pferd reiten.
Ach, guck mal.
Da, da bewegt sich was da oben.
Äh, ein bisschen verbacktes Pferd.
Musst du hier nicht reiten?
Doch, ich muss reiten.
Aber irgendwie check ich nicht, was ich genau machen muss,
weil aufs Pferd klicken ging nicht.
Äh, hallo?
Ich muss reiten.
Ich weiß das, ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern.
Ich muss hier definitiv reiten.
Ist das verbuggt?
Ah, nee, ich muss einfach ein bisschen nach rechts laufen.
Oh Mann.
Ob das wirklich eine gute Idee ist?
Kommt schon, klar.
Sie macht das nicht zum ersten Mal.
Aber sie ist bisher noch nie alleine geritten.
Ich kann das, ich bin kein Kind.
River!
Ja, ich stand einfach an der falschen Seite.
Worauf wartest du? Komm schon.
Hey, warte auf mich.
Jetzt darf ich da wahrscheinlich drauf.
Steht praktischerweise
noch ein Pferd für mich dabei.
Ich frag mich, ob Nile schon von dem Pferd runtergekommen ist.
Eva!
Was für ein Sp...
Ach, zum Maiskolben damit?
Tolle Übersetzung.
Oh, Pfeiltasten.
Was? Leertasten zum Kalobieren.
Jetzt ziehen sie aber alle Register vom RPG-Maker.
Bam.
Shracked?
Danke dir. Autsch.
Wem muss ich jetzt hinterher reiten?
Einfach rumreiten, oder?
Nicht in den Busch reiten?
Ja, haben wir es geschafft.
Wo ist das nächste Moment...
Das Pferd...
Ich speichere mal.
Wo ist das nächste Momento?
Memento?
Oder wie auch immer das Ding heißt.
Wo ist eigentlich Johnny?
Äh.
Hier, dieses Momento wird uns weiterhelfen.
Aber ich setz mich nicht nochmal auf dieses Pferd.
Besorg die restlichen Memory-Links.
Hab ich doch.
Vorbereiten.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas verpasst hier?
Nee, ne?
Ich hab eigentlich alles.
Ich hab alle Links.
Johnny ist auch hier noch am rumreiten.
Wir sind fertig.
Was zur Hölle spielst du das?
Weil es ein geiles Game ist.
Eines der am besten geschriebenen Storys der letzten paar Jahre in dem Spiel.
Oh nee, ich hab's wieder verkackt.
Wart mal.
Hm.
Wisst ihr was, ich klick jetzt einfach sinnlos rum.
Ich hab keinen Bock auf diese dummen Spielchen.
Äh.
Sag mal, hab ich jetzt...
Hab ich jetzt alles hier drinnen gefunden?
Ist das Absicht, dass ich jetzt vom Pferd dieses Ding auslösen muss?
Wahrscheinlich.
Aktivieren.
200 IQ.
900 IQ.
Sind wir im Krankenhaus, würde ich sagen.
Johnny, die Diagnose steht fest.
Fragezeichen.
Dr. Lee.
Ja, wir sind uns einig, was die Ergebnisse angeht.
Leider.
Und dieses Schicksal teilen sie mit vielen Menschen,
die von einer tiefgreifenden Entwicklungsstörung betroffen sind.
kommt die Diagnose spät.
Hätten sie davon schon gewusst, als sie noch klein waren,
hätten sie davon schon gewusst, als sie noch klein waren,
hätte es ihnen vieles ersparen können.
River, haben sie irgendwelche Bücher darüber?
Dieses hier ist von Tony Edwood.
Er ist eine Koryphäe auf diesem Gebiet.
Gibt es den Typ wirklich?
Sie können es erstmal ausleihen, kostenlos.
Brennen sie uns nur nicht damit durch.
Danke, Doc.
Nun, sind sie beide ein Paar?
Sie sind ohne sonstige rechtliche Bindung.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Nun, ich könnte sie an einen
spezialisierten Therapeuten
überweisen, wenn sie das möchten.
Gibt es irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten in ihrer Beziehung?
Nein.
Für River ist das ganz klar.
Johnny sieht das mit Sicherheit komplett anders.
Und wie sehen sie das?
Nein. Alles in Ordnung.
Wie auch immer,
sie sollten das Buch ebenfalls lesen.
Der Sibaro. Der Sibaro hat hier wieder den Wikipedia-Artikel rausgekramt.
Tony Edward ist ein britischer klinischer Psychologe. Er ist auf das Asperger-Syndrom spezialisiert und hat zahlreiche Bücher und andere Medien über dieses Thema veröffentlicht.
Das bekannteste und zahlreiche Sprachen übersetzte Buch ist Asperger-Syndrom.
Der deutsche Titel lautet Das Asperger-Syndrom. Das erfolgreiche Praxishandbuch für Eltern und Therapeuten.
Also sprich, das hat der Doktor gerade River gegeben.
Und ich glaube spätestens in diesem Moment ist klar, dass das Spiel uns sagen will, River ist Autist.
Es wird ihnen helfen, den Zustand ihrer Partnerin zu verstehen.
WPPD trollt wieder übelst rum.
Lieber nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Also Johnny, komm jetzt. Stell dich mal nicht so an.
Nun gut, das ist ihre Entscheidung.
Für die vorläufige Behandlung gibt es die sogenannte Hypotherapie. Die könnte ihr helfen.
Eine Ranch nördlich von hier bietet sie an. Ihr könntet das in die Wege leiten.
Ach, deswegen waren sie Pferderennen, Reiten, Freund.
Ich hab's dir doch gesagt.
Tö, Dr. Rosalie wusste schon die ganze Zeit.
Wollte bloß nicht spoilern.
Guck mal, jetzt kriegen wir auch erzählt, was wäre Tony, Tony, Tony Dings.
Wumms, Edward S.
Der Autor einer Buchreihe über Rivers Störung.
Ne, das können wir doch nicht aufmachen.
Entschuldigen Sie, könnten Sie bitte die Uhr leise stellen?
Sie kann das Ticken nicht gut ertragen.
Ist nicht so schlimm, ich halte es schon aus.
Kein Problem, das mache ich gerne.
Falls es noch etwas gibt, was Sie beunruhigt, sagen Sie mir einfach Bescheid.
Ja, wenn Ärzte nur so nett wären, beziehungsweise Sprechstunden helfen.
Hier aktuell würden die eher sagen, piss dich, Alter, dann wart woanders.
Zumindest habe ich den Eindruck, in vielen...
...Praxen, dass es die überhaupt nicht mehr juckt.
Dr. Rosalie.
Hm, das erklärt wohl die Uhren im Haus.
Könnt ihr euch noch an Anfang erinnern?
Da sind wir durch das Haus und alle Uhren haben nicht mehr getickt.
Guck mal, da ist wieder das Schnabeltier.
Was hat das mit dem Schnabeltier auf sich?
Ein Plüsch-Schnabeltier.
Ich kann es nicht fassen, dass diese Scheußlichkeiten so früh in Erinnerung auftaucht.
Da hat jemals ein Plüschtier wohl sehr sorgsam behandelt.
Und hatte, was Tiere angeht, einen ziemlich miserablen Geschmack.
Nicht mehr lange, sie werden dich gleich aufrufen.
Okay.
Jetzt wissen wir es offiziell.
Auch wenn wir es vorher schon geahnt haben und ich es vor dem ersten Mal spielen noch im Hinterkopf hatte.
River ist... hat Asperger.
Äh.
Was?
Moment.
Habe ich... habe ich was vergessen?
Moment. Ich habe...
Äh.
Wo habe ich vergessen, was einzusammeln?
Eine einfache, gelb-braune Handtasche.
Äh. So?
Bipp, bipp, bipp, bipp.
So?
Oh, Big Brain. Big Brain Place.
Big Brain.
Aktivieren.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet jetzt?
Irgendwie im Theater oder sowas?
Und jetzt ist Johnny ziemlich jung.
Die Porkers.
Passt.
Äh, nicht passt.
Psst. Schau.
Ich weiß.
Ich kann auch nicht glauben, dass er...
...für sie diesen Film bezahlt hat.
Nein, du Idiot.
Schau, wir sind gesprungen.
Johnny ist jetzt ziemlich jung.
Was ist Johnny?
14?
Der Bengel ist allein im Kino.
Was für ein Versager.
Du gehst ständig allein ins Kino.
Äh.
Das ist was anderes.
Niemand ist kompetent genug, mein Gespann zu verstehen.
Aber das mal außen vor.
Wie kann sich jemand diesen Müll hier antun?
Und daraus folgt, dass der Film auf Hand...
Was?
Oh, Reading.
Reading.
Reading Skills, Max.
Und daraus folgt, dass der Film auf der Handlungsebene wie auch der Meta-Ebene ein völliger Reinfall ist.
Natürlich.
Komm schon, gehen wir.
Was?
Ach ja, richtig.
Go, go, go.
Gehen wir mal Johnny hinterher gucken, was da los ist.
Was macht Johnny da?
Oh, was?
Ich rede nicht mit Emotien, Elton.
Grammatik, mein lieber Watson.
Sei bloß ruhig.
Grammatik ist ja nicht mal ein ganzer Satz.
Lass uns einfach Mementos schauen.
Äh, nein.
Damentoilette.
Herrentoilette.
Was macht denn Johnny da?
Lass mich raten.
Johnny wartet auf River und River ist nicht gekommen.
Huh?
Das klingt doch passend.
Okay, die Typen haben alle nichts mit der Story zu tun.
Das ist jetzt die dritte Person, die du entfernt hast.
Ja, ist doch egal, können wir immer noch gesetten.
Äh, Moment.
Nochmal Johnny.
Doppelt Johnny.
Versetzt worden.
Du kannst dich gut in deinesgleichen einfühlen, wie ich sehe.
Okay, was muss ich denn machen?
Ey, Dr. Watts ist so ein Spast.
Huh, hier ist nichts.
Tut mir leid, das sagen zu müssen, aber ich fürchte, wir müssen ihn nochmal ausquetschen.
Viel Erfolg.
Wenigstens sind hier diesmal keine Oliven.
Johnny ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut drauf.
River!
Du warst die ganze Zeit da drin?
Ich hab im Foyer auf dich gewartet.
Ich dachte schon, du wärst nicht gekommen.
Warum bist du rausgegangen?
Ich dachte, wir wollen den Film gemeinsam sehen.
Was?
Das sollte ich dich fragen.
Ja, für River ist das ganz klar.
Sie sitzen gemeinsam drin und gucken den Film.
Man muss nicht zusammensitzen, um den Film zu gucken.
Man kann im gleichen Raum sitzen, um den Film zu gucken.
Das reicht.
In Rivers Logik ist das vollkommen klar.
Wie meinst du das?
Wir haben den Film noch zusammen angeschaut und plötzlich bist du rausgegangen.
Ich habe den Film noch zusammen angeschaut und plötzlich bist du rausgegangen.
Wie meinst du das?
Wir haben ihn nicht zusammen angeschaut.
Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass du da bist.
Wenn du mich gesehen hast, warum bist du nicht zu mir gekommen?
Was macht das für einen Unterschied?
Ich meine, wir wollten uns den Film zusammen angucken.
Wir haben uns den selben Film im selben Raum angeschaut.
Tja, Johnny.
Lull.
Was hast du?
Du bist so merkwürdig.
Möchtest du den Film jetzt nicht mehr mit mir zusammen anschauen?
Klar will ich das.
Komm, lass uns reingehen, bevor es vorbei ist.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich sollte jetzt eine clevere Bemerkung machen.
Dein Gefühl täuscht dich.
Hoffentlich wartet drin die nächste Mitfahrgelegenheit.
Gehen wir rein.
Ne, hier dürfen wir nicht rein.
Jetzt dürfen wir bloß da rein.
Zack.
Fertig.
Da ist er wieder, das Plüschtier.
Das Plüschtnabeltier.
Das ist erstaunlich oft am Start.
Ich habe vergessen, was es damit auf sich hat.
Ich bin jetzt genauso gespannt wie ihr.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was damit gewesen ist.
Nein.
Verdammt, kein Big Brain.
Okay, fast Big Brain.
Aktivieren.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich glaube, dieses Schnabeltier wächst mir so langsam ans Herz.
Hauptsächlich aus praktischen Gründen, aber immerhin.
River in der Schule.
Komm schon, Junge.
Hast du keine Eier?
Äh.
Doch, das schon.
Hör mal.
Vielleicht war das doch keine so tolle Idee.
Ach, guck mal.
Da ist Nick.
Wieder am Start.
Ach Gott, was soll denn schon passieren?
Denk doch mal nach.
Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, ist, sie sagt nein.
Du schlenderst weiter, als ob nichts wäre.
Niemand wird jemals etwas erfahren.
Alle halten dich immer noch für cool.
Man's not hot.
Und wenn sie jemand davon erzählt, oder mich anschreit,
jetzt reiß dich mal zusammen, du Arschlamm.
Oder, oder wenn sie ja sagt, was mache ich dann?
Aber eigentlich nein, mein.
Jetzt mach mal einen Halblamm, wer tut denn sowas?
Und wenn sie mir eine Enzyklopädie ins Gesicht schmeißt, ich hab nicht mal einen Helm dabei.
Oh Gott, ich bin so dermaßen schlecht vorbereitet.
Alter, keine Panik.
Bauch rein, Brust raus.
Und hör auf, dich wie ein Waschlapp mal aufzuführen.
Genau, sag ihm, wo es lang geht.
Alles wird gut, dreh dich einfach um.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Ja, die Sache mit den Grills.
Hey, was tust du?
Psst.
Auf geht's, Johnny.
Komm, gib alles.
Äh...
Ich bin Johnny.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Johnny.
Ich komme hier zufällig vorbei.
Hallo? Kannst du mich hören?
Ja.
Na klar.
Wieso hast du dann nicht...
Egal.
Ganz schön cooles Schnabeltier hast du.
Das ist der krasseste Anmachspruch, den ich je gehört hab, Johnny.
Ja.
Der ist fast so gut, wie kannst du schwimmen.
Ich würde dich gerne...
Nein, nein, egal.
Was liest du da?
Ein Buch.
Über Schnabeltiere?
Nein.
Oh.
Das finde ich toll.
Über Leuchttürme.
Wenn River wüsste, dass sie später mal einen eigenen Leuchtturm hat.
Hä?
Es gibt noch genau 16 Leuchttürme mit fernsehnschen...
Linsen zweiter Ordnung.
Ja.
nicht warum kein datum keine uhrzeit ja river ist da halt sehr konkret und direkt naja wie
wäre es an diesem samstag um 8 eva ich glaube das system hängt ja ja ich nehme an die einzelheiten
klären wir dann später guck mal wie sie sogar hingekriegt hat dass river ein bisschen schüchtern
guckt ja ich gehe mal da schaust du mich so erwartungsvoll an du meinst sicher dass ich
jetzt noch einmal aussprechen wie unglaublich peinlich diese vorstellung war vergiss es den
gefallen werde ich dir nicht tun lass ihn doch er war eben noch ein kind gerade du solltest ja
wissen wie man sich da fühlt was wie was heißt was soll das heißen halt die klappe wir müssen
weiter halt die klappe
ist nicht mein name ein schnabelplüschtier ein hässliches schnabelplüschtier was zum teufel war
das denn man wieso ich habe mich verabredet das war erbärmlich an deiner stelle wäre ich da einfach
reingeplatzt und hätte die kleine sofort abgecheckt und weggekocht ungefähr so hey du ausgehen ich du
jetzt das ist einfach schrecklich ich weiß aber es wäre immer noch besser als das was du gerade
durchgezogen hast
und ich dem menschen es aber selber auch sagen muss ich muss weil ich kein burned out JAMDAGE
weißt du was du tust ich als mittelalter dörrige wikle toca
hat sie die entzweiung ins gesicht geschwissen nein halt die klappe man
alter fischt ich
siehst du ich bin nicht der einzige
ich bin nicht der einzige leute immer sagen muss wenn ich die klappe halten
wie konnte ich mich nur von dir überreden lassen dieses dämliche fach zu gehen
komm stell dich nicht anders macht spaß nur weil man meinen kann
shores
Die Heavy Breathing Cat, falls sie noch jemand kennt.
Übung macht den Meister.
Klar, sicher.
Nach diesem Schuljahr werde ich nie wieder einen Pinsel in die Hand nehmen.
Fenris Blue.
Ja, das sagen wirklich Leute, ernsthaft.
So blöd es klingt, das ist...
Man glaubt es nicht, aber es gibt es.
Hör auf zu mosern.
Ich bin mir sicher, du wirst lernen, es zu mögen.
Wie, dafür gab es keinen Memory Link?
Die F.
Ist hier ein Memory Link?
Leonardo da Vinci hat geübt, indem er Eier malte.
Fässer sind wie sehr große Eier.
Klingt logisch.
So gesehen werdet ihr alle sehr große da Vinci's.
Natürlich.
Was sonst?
Ist hier irgendwas?
Niemand?
Guck mal, Johnny und River.
Wirklich niemand?
Wenn das so ist.
River, warum gibst du uns nicht die Antwort?
Äh.
Ich weiß, dass du die Antwort kennst.
Wir warten, River.
Na schön.
Er stach am 3. August 1942 in See.
Geht es um Columbus?
1492 in See.
Von der spanischen Stadt Palos de la Frontera aus.
Die 1322 gegründet wurde und an...
Ja bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Ist gut, ist gut.
Ich wollte nur das Datum.
Seht ihr das?
War das jetzt so schwer?
Haben alle Leute ein so fotografisches Gedächtnis?
Nicht wirklich.
Obwohl ich glaube, dass ihr Mustergedächtnis oft sehr ausgeprägt ist.
Achtung, sie kommt zu uns rüber.
Altep, altep.
Hahaha.
Gucken sie sich Bron an oder was?
In der Schule.
Altep erhalten.
Was ist die Notiz zu Altep?
Moment.
Lebensretter.
Da ist was dran.
Abgeschlossen.
Nur in der Mittagspause geöffnet.
Geht es denn weiter?
Da.
Wie wär's?
Beim nächsten Mal solltet ihr Flaschen mal besser etwas besser sein.
Eine Aula.
Die können wir für später gepostet.
Und die müssen wir brauchen.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass die Spielfeldmarkierungen in seinem Kopf rechteckig sind.
Hahaha.
Das stimmt.
Na gut.
Der Johnny hat wahrscheinlich nie wieder Basketball gespielt.
John.
Na schön.
Du hast gewonnen.
Jawohl.
Yeah.
Ah, ist Mittagspause, weil da alle hinrennen?
Ja, ist Mittagspause.
Hallo, Morbid Martin.
Klar ist sie was Besonderes.
Besonders langweilig.
Ich meine, schau sie dir doch mal an.
River ist voll niedlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die alle haben.
Wie sie da sitzt, allein, den ganzen Tag, mit dieser gruselig deformierten Ente als Plüschtier.
Das ist keine deformierte Ente, das ist ein Schnabeltier, Nick.
Ein was? Hör auf, die Tiere auszudenken.
Ja, Nick hat nicht so ein Big Brain.
Wie auch immer, sie ist so dermaßen neben der Spur, als wäre sie von einem anderen Planet oder so.
Ich weiß, ist das nicht cool?
Sicher, wenn man auf Aliens und solches Zeug steht, dann wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber mal im Ernst, wenn du durchgeknallt sein willst, warum hängst du nicht einfach mit den Emos und Gothics rum?
Aha.
Naja, zum einen will ich mir nicht die Haare ruinieren.
Und die Tatsache, dass wir schon unsere Schubladen für sie haben, macht es nicht besser.
Sieh mal, Nick.
Ich will einfach kein durchschnittlicher Junge in einem Ozean durchschnittlicher Leute sein.
Da sagt Johnny was.
Warum zur Hölle sollte es denn deine Identität ändern, mit ihr zusammen zu sein?
Ich meine, du wärst dann einfach ein Typ, der mit einem schüchternen Mädchen rumhängt.
Sie ist nicht einfach nur schüchtern, Nick.
Irgendwas an ihr ist anders.
Naja, anders zu sein ist auch nicht immer so toll.
Weißt du denn überhaupt, ob sie wirklich will...
Was?
Weißt du denn überhaupt, ob sie das wirklich will, anders sein?
Vielleicht will sie einfach anders sein.
Vielleicht will sie einfach nur dazugehören, so wie alle anderen auch.
Wir wissen mittlerweile, das möchte River ganz bestimmt nicht.
Und wenn das so ist, wäre es nicht hilfreich, sie in die andere Richtung zu drängen, oder?
Hör mal, Nick.
Die Sache ist die, ich weiß, was ich brauche.
Der John kennt sich aber aus.
Und dieses Mädchen hat es.
Na, da ist er aber für sein Alter schon gut dabei, der Johnny.
Also willst du sie, weil sie etwas hat, aber nicht um ihr selbst willen.
Sehr philosophisch für die Schule.
Das ist eiskalt, Mann.
Ich hoffe nur, du weißt, was du tust.
Ich weiß es.
Ich glaube übrigens, du hast Unrecht.
Die Menschen sind nicht durchschnittlich, jeder ist auf seine Art etwas Besonderes.
Das erzählen doch nur irgendwelche Omas.
Guck mal, seine Tasche, die hat er später immer noch.
Moment mal, dieser Typ ist so eine Art Hipster, der sich an andere Menschen dranwanzt.
Das ist irgendwie, äh, verstörend.
Ich weiß, äh, Little Samson, keine Ahnung, ob die 13, 14 sind.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, ja, oder vielleicht 16, 17.
Weißt du, manchmal möchte ich unseren Kunden einen ordentlichen Kopfnuss verpassen.
So ist die Highschool.
So ist die Highschool, jeder ist ein Spast.
Aber hey, willkommen im Club.
Heißt das, äh, Sibaros sagt, heißt das, dass Johnny River nur will, weil sie nicht wie, wie alle anderen 0815 Menschen sein will?
Sieht aktuell so aus.
Aber, wie gesagt, am Ende ergibt das alles wunderbar Sinn.
Warte mal, darum ging es also bei dem Gespräch an der Klippe.
Was an der Klippe?
Hat er ihr erzählt, warum er sich an sie rangemacht hat?
Oder wie war das jetzt?
Hä?
Vermutlich.
Dann kriegte sie einen Sprung in der Schüssel und begann diese unheimlichen Hasen zu basteln, stimmt's?
Weil er ihr die ewig zurückliegende Sache gebeichtet hat?
Man könnte sie durchaus als nachtragend bezeichnen.
Übrigens, Nick, Nick, Spoilern hier, ne?
Ich sag's nochmal.
Falls du das Game kennst.
Nein.
Mein Gefühl sagt mir, dass da noch mehr ist.
Dann hol schon mal deinen Hut, Sherlock.
Komm, ich glaube, unsere Mitfahrgelegenheit lehnt da vorne am Tisch.
Äh, ich brauch noch ein, ein, äh, Momento, wo hab ich das vergessen?
Lelouch O.W., hi.
Guck mal, ob River vielleicht noch ein Momento hat.
Von den Hintergründen mal abgesehen, ist es ziemlich erstaunlich, dass die beiden tatsächlich in der Highschool zusammenkamen.
Wie viele von diesen Pärchen bleiben zusammen schon länger als ein, äh, welche, wie viele von diesen Pärchen?
Äh.
Oh, ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Wie viele von diesen Pärchen bleiben heutzutage schon länger als ein Monat zusammen, hä?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir war.
Mit meinen Mädels lief damals alles glatt.
Ja, Watts ist klar.
Aha.
So glatt, dass sie mir im Handumdrehen alle wieder entglitten.
Klingt, als könnte das stimmen.
Ah, nice.
Oh nein, jetzt kommt wieder irgendein Spruch.
Oh nein, ich wusste es, ich wusste es.
Dr. Watts.
Ruined.
Und cool, Eva.
WTF.
Nochmal, man stört niemals jemanden in seinem Kamehameha.
Äh, Morbid Martin, sag mal, was hast du eigentlich mittlerweile für eine Internetleitung?
Ich hab VDSL 100.
What?
Vorbereiten.
Weiter geht's.
Jetzt nähern wir uns langsam Johnnys Kindheit.
Wo wir dann endlich verstehen, was eigentlich mit Johnny und River und was da eigentlich los ist.
Äh.
Ich klick jetzt einfach mal.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wie ist das?
Wie man es eigentlich lösen müsste.
So, hä?
Big Brain.
Intuitiv hier.
Intuition.
Big Brain.
Keine Ahnung, was ich sagen wollte.
Ähm.
Weiter.
Hi, hast du schon Battalion 1944 versucht?
Noch nicht versucht.
Ich dachte, es kommt erst nächste Woche oder so.
Funktioniert bei dir Shadowplay?
Ja.
Qualität ist übel scheiße.
Du musst die Qualität hochstellen in den Settings.
Die, die, die, die, mit wieviel MBit da aufnimmt.
Wo sind wir hier jetzt?
So, Mama, ich geh jetzt zur Schule.
Mach's gut, Joey.
Ich hab das schon mal durchgespielt, vieles Batman.
Ja, vor drei Jahren oder so.
So genau kann ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich weiß nur, dass die Story wirklich herzzerreißend war.
Mein kleiner Junge, er wird so schnell erwachsen.
Auf geht's, Johnny.
Moment, hat sie, hat sie, hat sie wieder Joey gesagt?
Mein Gott.
Und wenn er ein Mädchen wäre, würde sie ihn dann auch mit dem Namen sagen?
Ja.
Auch mit dem Namen seines Großvaters ansprechen.
Stimmt.
Sie nennt ihn ja nicht, sie nennt ihn ja Joey und nicht Johnny.
Ich, ich überles das immer, weil ich, ich les das zu schnell.
Die Mutter sagt ja zu Johnny immer Joey.
Das wäre gar nicht mal so schlimm.
Er endet immerhin auf I.
Joey, Juey, Julji.
Ja, genau.
Wenn du so, wenn das so knuffig klingt, wieso heiratest du nicht einfach?
Bäh, eifersüchtig, was?
Oh ja, extrem eifersüchtig.
Hier gibt es doch einen Fußball.
Den können wir noch nicht.
Eine Uhr, die tickt?
Eine tickende Uhr.
Keiner mehr echt auf die Nerven geht.
Da hat er recht.
Was, was haben wir hier?
Das Gurkenglas wieder.
Nicht schon wieder.
Ein Glas eingelegte Gurken.
Du bist ziemlich leicht zu beeindrucken.
Was gibt's hier oben?
Diverse Bücher mit unleserlichen Titeln.
Gibt's hier sonst noch was?
Nee, ne?
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Irgendwas hab ich übersehen.
Ah, hier.
Schade, dass du keine PS4 hast.
Sonst könntest du The Last Guardian spielen, Max.
Ist von der Story her ein ganz großes Kino.
Ich hab ne PS4.
Seit Release hab ich ne PS4.
Das wollte ich auch nochmal spielen, The Last Guardian.
Ich hab Ico gespielt.
Ich hab Shadow of the Colossus gespielt.
Was ja so quasi die zwei...
Zwei Vorgänger, wenn man so will, waren.
So Big Brain Plays wieder.
Easy.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, was in Johnnys Kindheit so passiert ist.
Es riecht nach Verwesung.
Wo sind wir?
Das sieht nicht wie Johnnys Kindheit aus.
Eva?
WTF ist das?
Was macht das in Johnnys Gedanken?
Oder in Johnnys Erinnerung?
Seine nächste Erinnerung.
Schön, aber warum sieht hier...
Was?
Schön, aber warum sieht's hier aus wie in Laputa aus?
Gute Frage.
Die Erinnerungen verbinden sich nicht richtig miteinander.
Muss sich wohl um eine Fehlfunktion der Maschine handeln.
Schon wieder?
Beim letzten Update war die Behauptung, sie sei nun für mindestens ein halbes Jahr idiotensicher.
Äh...
Unsere IT-Abteilung besteht aus lauter Schwachköpfen.
Egal, halb so schlimm.
Vielleicht haben wir ja abgespeichert.
Damit könnten wir es schon hinkriegen.
In Ordnung, aber ich werde ihm nichts über das hier erzählen.
Solange wir erfolgreich sind, muss er es auch nicht erfahren.
Tja, ich glaube, das war's.
Wir können hier nichts tun.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Bereit für die Finalisierung?
Ladies first.
Zu schade. Ich hätte gern mehr erfahren.
Oh, wir erfahren auch noch mehr. Wir erfahren alles.
Zweiter Akt.
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die festsitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels.
Oh, ich glaube, jetzt geht's langsam los.
Wo hier Social Heulen angesagt ist.
Halten Sie bitte Abstand.
Sie werden nicht einfach aufwachen, aber sie brauchen volle Konzentration.
Jetzt sind wir wieder beim alten Johnny.
Und das ist alles, was ich als alter Narr weiß.
Tja, tut mir leid. Ich bin wohl keine große Hilfe.
Dann muss das so reichen.
No happy meal for you. Warum?
Warum kackt die O.W.L. richtig rein?
Dr. Watts, äh, okay, jetzt müssen wir nur noch den Wunsch mit Ihren frühesten Kindheitserinnerungen verbinden.
Dann legen wir den Schalter um und zack, im Handnotdrehen stehen Sie auf dem Mond.
Ich hab eine Frage.
Äh, what?
Wenn Sie Lilly verschwinden lassen können, dann bedeutet das, dass Sie die Welt verändern können.
Warum tun Sie das nicht einfach noch einmal und erfüllen mir meinen Wunsch gleich hier und jetzt?
Das würde funktionieren, wenn dies Ihre wahren Erinnerungen wären.
Was soll das heißen?
Was ist das hier denn? Was bin ich?
Nur eine Kopie. Eine Leinwand, auf der wir arbeiten, wenn Sie es so wollen.
Was Sie selbst angeht, Sie sind nur ein Algorithmus, abgeleitet aus Johnny.
Gut genug für ein Abbild von ihm, aber längst nicht vollständig.
Wer ist Lilly? Lilly ist seine Betreuerin.
Seine Altenpflegerin.
Alles, was wir tun können, ist, dieses Bild auf logische Weise schlüssig zu ergänzen.
Wie ich einfach die Hälfte der Dialoge nicht richtig vorlese.
Wenn wir dann Ihren Wunsch in Ihrer Kindheit übertragen, generiert die Maschine ein neues Leben für Sie.
Eines, in dem dieser Wunsch in Erfüllung geht.
Dieses Ergebnis schreiben wir dann in das Gedächtnis des echten Johnnys.
Sie sehen also, selbst wenn Sie zufrieden mit uns sind, bleiben Sie.
Bleiben Sie doch nur ein Read-Only-Programm.
Ich meine, wir können Sie resetten, so oft wir wollen, und das reicht.
Ach, sei nicht so empfindlich. Es ist eh nicht real.
Wenn du das wirklich glaubst, warum machst du dir denn so viel Mühe, es ihm zu erklären?
Ich versuche, nur Zeit zu sparen.
Gehen wir.
Doktor, ist es das, was ich wirklich bin?
Die Arbeit einer ganzen Nacht.
Da geht's nicht weiter.
WTF?
Du hättest mich wenigstens vorwarten können, dass du noch als Kopf hier rumschwebst.
Ich kann es nicht leugnen, ich gehe einfach gerne mit dem Kopf voran.
Ich würde ja fragen, ob das ein Scherz sein soll, aber ich habe Angst vor der Antwort.
Ziehen wir es durch.
Ich komme mir in dieser Gestalt dumm genug vor.
Alles, was wir tun müssen, ist, seinen Wunsch von der spätesten Erinnerung zur frühesten zu transferieren.
Okay, jetzt kommen komische Schiebespielchen.
Ich meine, das war doch relativ simpel, ne?
Man musste...
Ja, ja, ich weiß noch, wie das funktioniert.
Das war ziemlich simpel.
Glaube ich, dass das irgendwie so ging.
Man musste es jetzt einfach durchleiten.
Das war nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Ach nee, Moment, Moment.
So einfach ist es doch nicht.
Wenn ich das hier jetzt rumdrehe...
Oh Gott, Logikspielchen.
Wenn ich das jetzt rumdrehe, passt das hier nicht mehr.
Moment. Easy, easy.
Fangen wir mal links an.
Okay.
Hier ist eine Uhr.
Das einzige, was sich hier deckt, ist die Uhr.
Und das heißt, ich muss die Uhr auf jeden Fall auf diese Seite machen.
Was anderes bleibt mir nicht übrig.
Jetzt funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Hey, Eva, guck mal.
Omnomnomnomnom.
Der Typ, ey.
Lol.
Oh Mann.
Moment, ich transferiere in die falsche Richtung, ich Noob.
Hallo, Yoshi1997.
So, Moment.
Das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein.
So, hier rumdrehen.
Bam.
Easy.
Next.
Was gibt es hier?
Was hier gleich ist?
Das Buch.
Okay.
Das heißt, das Buch muss auf jeden Fall auf die linke Seite.
Sonst geht es nicht weiter.
So.
Wenn das Buch auf die linke Seite muss, dann muss der Hase auch auf die linke Seite.
Und da...
What?
Okay, dann geht es nur so.
Dann geht es nur so.
Äh.
Was?
Hä?
Moment.
Ich habe das gar nicht gelöst jetzt.
Egal.
Das Game Mightn't.
Ich habe es gelöst.
Es ist alles gut.
Easy.
Ding.
So, das wären dann alle, mit denen wir arbeiten können.
Bereit, auf den Knopf zu drücken?
Du kennst mich.
Du kennst mich doch.
Ich bin immer bereit.
Alles klar.
Dann schauen wir mal, was für Souvenirs Johnny uns vom Mond mitgebracht hat.
Ladies first.
Diesmal nicht, Süße.
Na, gucken wir mal, ob Johnny jetzt auf dem Mond war.
Das hier ist dasselbe Umgebung, wie in der letzten echten Erinnerung, auf die wir Zugriff
haben.
Normalerweise müsste sich doch wenigstens etwas geändert haben.
Irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Diese Erinnerungen.
Sie fühlen sich nicht so an, als wären sie einfach noch einmal passiert.
Ich weiß.
Sie sind exakt die gleichen!
Unglaublich!
Das Verlangen wurde doch transferiert, zum Mond zu fliegen, oder etwa nicht.
Doch wurde es.
Aber es funktioniert nicht!
Warum funktioniert es nicht?
Das ist genau das gleiche wieder!
Johnny?
Was für eine schöne Überraschung, wir haben seltenen Besuch.
Das ist genau das gleiche!
Mein Name ist Dr.
Eva Roserin.
Und das ist ... Was?
Ich sage das jetzt nicht zwei mal?
Dr. Nile Watts.
Ist Ihnen der Name Siegmund Agency of Life Generation geläufig?
Oh ja, also Sie beiden sind von der Agentur.
Das ist genau das gleiche nochmal.
Das trifft sich gut, ich habe gerade überlegt, Sie anzurufen.
Lilly, bring uns doch bitte etwas Tee.
Lilly?
Zack.
Also es hat sich nichts geändert.
Frier ihn auch ein.
Und jetzt?
Warte hier, ich gehe jetzt und sende das Verlangen-Signal noch einmal.
Pass auf, ob sich etwas ändert.
Die Übertragung war definitiv erfolgreich.
Hat sich was geändert?
Nicht einmal ein bisschen.
Wie ist das möglich?
Selbst wenn das Verlangen allein nicht ausreicht, warum ändert sich dann gar nichts?
Vielleicht braucht es einfach etwas Stimulation, um in Gang zu kommen.
Aus deinen früheren Erinnerungen?
So viel wie möglich.
Wie früh wir zurückgehen können.
Ja, auf geht's.
Hallo Cheesy-Pro.
Johnnys Wunsch zum Mond zu fliegen braucht etwas Stimulation, hm?
Also dann?
Oh, wir stimulieren.
Moon.
Was zum...
An der Kasse haben Sie gesagt, dass ein anderer Film läuft.
Äh, egal.
Macht es dir was aus, River?
Nein, ich mag diesen auch.
Okay, dann lass uns reingehen.
Okay.
Sie versuchen, ihm jetzt irgendwie einzuhämmern, dass er zum Mond fliegen will und Astronaut wird.
Hoffentlich reicht das für die Zündung.
Moment, wo ist eigentlich Nile?
Hier ist er nicht.
Was gibt das jetzt?
Zum Mond, Liebling.
Oh, Henry.
Oh Gott, was ist das für ein Film?
Okay, ich bin viel zu angespannt, um hochgeschwimmte zu konsumieren.
Wahrscheinlich sollte ich mal nachsehen, ob sich John irgendwas, ob sich Patron irgendwas verändert hat.
Lass mich raten, es hat sich nichts geändert.
Nope.
Alles unverändert.
Ich muss versuchen, irgendwie das anders zu machen.
Vielleicht kann man hier etwas versuchen.
Was macht eigentlich der Schnabeltier?
Steht da rum.
Was macht ihr denn noch hier?
Es geht gleich los.
Wenn wir uns nicht beeilen, sind die guten Plätze weg.
Okay, dann werden wir ihm jetzt beibringen, dass er Astronaut werden soll.
Das habe ich anders in Erinnerung.
Es muss sich was verändert haben.
Hey, nicht drängeln.
Okay.
Dann macht Nile jetzt...
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie eine Show oder sowas.
Moment mal.
Das ist keine echte Änderung.
Das ist...
Darf ich um eure Aufmerksamkeit bitten?
Wie ihr wisst, bin ich Repräsentant der gloriosen NASA.
Und ich bin heute hier, um euch alles darüber zu erzählen.
Hau rein, Timmy.
Aber ich schweife ab.
Sie wollen ihm jetzt ernsthaft eingehen, Astronaut zu werden.
Wie auch immer, ich weiß, dass sich viele von euch eine Frage stellen.
Wie groß ist die Chance, dass ich jemals etwas Großartiges machen kann,
wie zu einem Abenteuer in neue Welten aufzubrechen?
Den süßen Duft der Venus schnuppern, gegen den Uhrzeigersinn durch die Ringe des Saturns zu schwimmen.
Oder vielleicht einfach ein bisschen auf der dunklen Seite des Mondes abzuhängen.
Wir von der NASA glauben, dass jeder dazu das Zeug hat, wenn er sich nur richtig anstrengt.
Du könntest es sein.
Oder du.
Oder vielleicht...
Du.
Das wird auch nicht so.
Das wird auch nicht funktionieren.
Aber ich möchte gar nicht zum Mond.
Sogar Johnny sagt hier zu dem Zeitpunkt, er will nicht zum Mond.
Dann ist heute dein Glückstag.
Moment, was?
Wieso nicht?
Wieso willst du nicht zum Mond?
Was soll ich da?
Ah, zu diesem Zeitpunkt will Johnny auch nicht auf den Mond.
Ich bin glücklich hier auf der Erde.
Du willst überhaupt nicht hin?
Nicht mal ein kleines bisschen auf den Mond?
Nein, warum?
Nicht mal ein kleines bisschen?
Äh, ne?
Nun, als offizieller NASA Rekrutierungsoffizier, erzähle ich dir jetzt ein paar unglaubliche Fakten über den Mond.
Jetzt dreht er auf.
Um warm zu werden, der Mond ist 4,5 Milliarden Jahre alt.
Resident Sleeper, Resident Sleeper
Und wusstet ihr, dass seine Oberfläche so groß wie der afrikanische Kontinent ist.
Doch wirklich, wenn ich das bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla,
es wird Johnny nicht überzeugen.
Und weiter, das Licht braucht bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla. Es wird Johnny nicht überzeugen. Und weiter, das Licht braucht bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Und ja
Das wusste ich schon
Und das Beste zum Schluss
Leute, die zum Mond fliegen, werden reich und berühmt
Und wir alle kennen die Gleichung
Reich plus berühmt gleich
Groupies
Denkt dran, bei der Nase seid ihr alle willkommen
Besonders daran, wenn ihr brünett seid
Es zieht alles nicht bei Johnny
Johnny will nicht mehr zum Mond
Zumindest kleiner Johnny will nicht zum Mond
Na, wie war ich?
Die Nase will dich wahrscheinlich nicht anheuern
Ich habe alles gegeben
Willst du mal nachsehen, ob es was gebracht hat?
Natürlich, bin gleich zurück
Es hat natürlich nichts gebracht, ne?
Wenn ich jetzt mal rate
Bin zurück, erzähl
Grandioser Fehlschlag
Facepalm, nicht gut
Hey, lass dich nicht entmutigen
Ich bin sicher, dass wir immer noch was machen können
Und das wäre
Tja
Wir können uns nicht leisten
Dieses Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabelle
Oh
Er will ihn wirklich krampfhaft davon überzeugen
Aber können Sie sich die Mondlandungslotterie leisten?
Er will ihn ernsthaft überzeugen, auf den Mond zu fliegen
Aber er will nicht
Die Diagnose steht fest
Ja, genau genommen haben wir nur selten
Hey
Wussten Sie, dass die Mitarbeiter der Nase
Exzellente Krankenversicherungsleistung bekommen?
Tatsächlich
Sie beide und ihre Lieblingsfrau
Liebste
Polly reiten für Lau im All
Es zieht alles nicht
Zieh mal eine Hochzeit
Tolle Sache
Wir sind von der NASA
Ratet mal, wo ihr ganz
Mondänen Flitterwochen machen könnt
Nein, es zieht einfach nicht
Johnny will nicht
River?
Verdammt rutschig
Johnny
Hast du Guck
Ha, knapp
Weißt du was?
Es klappt einfach nicht
Ich bin nicht so gut, dass ich das nicht mache
Das ist mehr als einfach nicht klappen lassen
Das ist lächerlich
Wir sind Profis, verdammt
Ich mach diesen Job nicht, um die Gegend zu rennen und Leute anzuschreien
Nicht?
Ich glaube, es liegt einfach an unserem verdammt langen Tag
Hätte ich gewusst, dass wir die Nacht durcharbeiten, hätte ich Kaffee mitgenommen
Absolut
Du hättest mal den Film sehen sollen, den ich vorhin verbrochen habe
Welcher Film?
Siehst du, das meine ich
So kostbar unsere Zeit hier auch ist
In diesem Zustand kommen wir einfach nicht weiter
Machen wir Pause bis morgen früh
Hoffentlich hält Johnny bis dahin durch
Ich muss ein paar Anrufe machen
GG Eats
Das macht keinen Sinn
Wieso hat die Maschine nicht funktioniert?
Johnnys Wunsch, zum Mond zu fliegen, wurde erfolgreich übertragen
Und trotzdem
Gab es nach dem Transfer kein einziges Anzeichen dafür, dass er zum Mond wollte
Es sei denn, eine zweite Bedingung für seine Sehnsucht wurde dabei mitgeändert
Nur dann könnte der gleiche Wunsch zu zwei verschiedenen
Ergebnissen nach unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten führen
Ohne Zweifel spielt River eine wichtige Rolle bei der ganzen Sache
Wenn es also irgendwas gibt, was diese Veränderung verursacht haben kann, dann wäre sie die Hauptverdächtige
Aber was genau ist die Ursache?
River
Was genau hast du getan?
Sie baut Papierhasen
Und wir wissen immer noch nicht warum
Ah, die Sonne geht auf
Wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit
Aber...
Ich frage mich, ob Niall etwas herausgefunden hat.
So wie ich Niall kenne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Außer dumme Sprüche zu machen.
Igitt.
Man kann das Eichhörnchen ein bisschen herriechen.
Wo ist Niall jetzt?
Stellst du ihn hier irgendwo rum?
Ne.
Wie geht es John?
Wir verlieren ihn. Was treiben sie dann?
Wir sind einfach nicht vorwärts gekommen.
Tun sie etwas. Wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Falls sie ihren Kollegen suchen, er ist in der Küche.
Wann ist die Küche hier?
Ach, guck mal. Das sind die leeren Bilder.
Wo Johnny vorhin davor stand.
Und da ist sogar dieses komische Schnabeltier wieder drauf.
Scheint ja echt wichtig zu sein.
Ist die Küche hier gewesen?
Oder ist die Küche unten?
Ne, das ist das Klo.
Aber das ist kein 3000 Euro Klo.
Das habe ich gleich
fachmännisch im Blick analysiert.
Wo ist...
Wo ist denn Niall?
Wie heißt er eigentlich?
Heißt er Niall? Heißt er Neil?
Da ist er.
Nein, den Teil verstehe ich, aber...
Okay.
Hast du das in den Akten gecheckt?
Und warum nochmal wurden uns diese Informationen verschwiegen?
Oder dem Arzt in diesem Fall?
Woher hast du den Kaffee?
Ruhig.
Sprichst du mit der Zentrale?
Ja.
Ich erkläre es dir später.
Also Ruhe.
Okay, was mache ich jetzt bis Niall fertig ist?
Telefoniert hat?
Wo geht es denn hier lang?
Wir gehen mal kurz durchs Haus ein bisschen gucken.
Das Bad.
Wo sind eigentlich die Kinder?
Aber Mama, ich will nicht zur Schule.
Es ist Sonntag.
Easy.
Lass sie schlafen.
Mach mal.
Ich sage nichts.
Gibt sie irgendwas?
Buch ins Regal.
Sss.
Okay, wann ist Niall fertig telefonieren?
Ist er fertig?
Was hat denn Lilly zu der ganzen Sache zu sagen?
Hallo, ich will mit dir reden.
Die Kinder sollten doch zeitig ins Bad gehen.
Ja, nehm Platz.
Ich glaube ich habe sie verbuggt.
Ruhe ist verschlossen.
Hä, kickt man das auf?
Oh, wollen sie mich noch was fragen?
Lilly, Tommy zu...
Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Oh, hey.
Bevor Johnny das Bewusstsein verlor, erzählte er mir, dass sie beide bald eintreffen würden.
Er sagte, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr selbst die Gelegenheit dazu haben würde.
Deshalb bat er mich ihn nicht mehr.
nicht unbeträchtliche Menge an Beta-Blockern verabreicht bekommen.
Und was für ein Zufall, die haben ein kleines bisschen Nebenwirkung auf so komische Dinge namens Gedächtnis.
Beta-Blocker?
Johnny hatte keine Herzprobleme, oder?
Anscheinend nicht.
Was uns zur Frage führt, ob diese Nebenwirkungen nicht die eigentliche Absicht waren.
Vor allem bei derart großen Mengen, der Einfluss auf sein Erinnerungsvermögen muss immens gewesen sein.
Du meinst, das hat uns den Weg zu den Kindheitserinnerungen versperrt?
Das ist jedenfalls kein Maschinenfehler, soviel kann ich dir sagen.
Die IT-Abteilung hat mich ganz schön angemurzt, weil ich sie beschuldigt habe.
Und was jetzt?
Na rein in die Maschine!
Ich habe die Frequenzmodifikationen bekommen, mit denen können wir die Barriere überwinden.
Und wenn wir erstmal in seiner Kindheit angekommen sind, ist es sicher früh genug, um den Wunsch erfolgreich zu übertragen.
Worauf warten wir dann?
Es gibt noch eine Sache.
Es gibt immer noch eine Sache.
Um die neue Frequenz zu aktivieren, brauchen wir einen Auslöser.
Einen Auslöser?
Etwas in den versperrten Erinnerungen, das sehr stark präsent ist.
Und wir müssen es Johnny geben, damit er seine Erinnerungen wecken kann.
Und wie sollen wir das machen? Wir wissen so gut wie nichts über seine Kindheit.
Und selbst wenn wir ein Kindheitsfoto fänden, Johnny ist nach wie vor bewusstlos.
Ja, also sind wir keinen Schritt weiter.
Weißt du, seit Noras Fall letztes Jahr hatten wir keinen Auftrag mehr, der mich so saumäßig genervt hat.
Geht mir genauso.
Das bringt mich nur rum. Ich gehe mal etwas frische Luft schnappen.
Gut.
Nein, mach das.
Da ist er wieder.
Ähm, hab meinen Kaffee vergessen.
Alter Lahn.
Ich gehe dem jetzt mal hinterher.
Es stinkt. Ja, nach dem Eichhörnchen, was er überfahren hat.
Das überfahrene Tier, Eva. Es stinkt.
Es stinkt.
Ich weiß, daran bist du schuld. Du hast es überfahren.
Was ist los? Die Kinder schlafen noch.
Moment mal.
Letzte Erinnerung, die, wo wir feststecken.
Sie hatte denselben Geruch.
Wie, das überfahrene Tier?
Worüber reden sie beide?
Die Geruchsrezeptoren sind direkt mit dem lymbischen System des Gels verbunden, Lilly.
Äh, was? Verstehen sie nicht?
Auch egal.
Ja, egal.
Er meint, dass der Geruchssinn wahrscheinlich...
Der tiefste Sinn ist, um Erinnerungen zu wecken.
Wir können den Geruch als Stimulation nutzen, um einen Weg zu seinen Kindheitserinnerungen freizulegen.
Alter, wollen sie jetzt Johnny entver...
Johnny hat noch ein, zwei Tage zu leben, ja?
Und sie wollen ihm ein verwestes Eichhörnchen aufs Bett legen.
Obwohl Johnny bewusstlos ist, ist er immer noch empfänglich dafür.
Ich glaube, ich hab den Zusammenhang nicht kapiert.
Okay, das ist gut. Das ist fantastisch.
Jetzt muss ich nur was von dem überfahrenen Eichhörnchen holen.
Ja, ich werde... Moment mal.
Warum sollte ich das dir holen?
Du hast es überfahren.
Genau. Ich habe meinen Beitrag geleistet.
Oh, du Sch...
Sie können meine Handschuhe haben.
Es sind zwar eigentlich keine Wegwerf-Handschuhe, aber das wird sich danach ändern.
So, wir speichern mal.
So, gehen wir das überfahrene Eichhörnchen holen.
Guck, sie hat sogar Handschuhe an.
Oh man, soll ich jetzt da runterlaufen?
Noch mehr Eichhörnchen.
Hm, dann gehen wir mal das Eichhörnchen holen.
Es ist zu gefährlich.
Naja.
Okay.
Also, in die Box.
Sie wollen allen Ernstes...
Schau dir den totes Eichhörnchen auf die...
Naja.
Eine...
Ihr wollt...
Was?
Ihr wollt eine Pause machen?
Ja, dann geht mal kurz aufs Klo.
Geht mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ich mache kurz Pause.
Ich denke mal, das Spiel geht wahrscheinlich noch so eine...
Wie lange geht das ungefähr noch?
Ich würde mal sagen, so 45 Minuten.
Stunde?
45 Minuten bis Stunde?
Ja, auf geht's, Leute.
Kurz Pause.
Dann...
Geht's weiter.
Geht mal alle aufs Klo.
Geh ich auch mal.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich warte jetzt noch 1-2 Minuten, dass die Leute vom Klo wiederkommen können.
Dann geht's weiter.
Gerade mal kurz gucken, was auf YouTube so abgeht.
Wie man ein neues Video einfach schon mal 15k aufruft, wenn er halt vor ein paar Stunden hat.
Einfach nur, weil da Cheater im Titel steht.
Und dabei wollte ich das Video gar nicht freischalten.
Und 330 Kommentare hat.
Lull.
Und 1 Minute noch.
Ist ein gutes Video.
Mir hat die Aufnahme nicht gefallen, deswegen wollte ich es nicht freischalten.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, also warum ich das Video heute freigeschaltet habe.
Ich glaube, das Problem war, dass ich beim Upload.
Normalerweise habe ich standardmäßig eingestellt, dass beim Video Upload, das auf Privat gestellt wird.
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich wahrscheinlich es nicht, also irgendwie von Privat auf halt nicht mehr Privat gestellt beim Upload.
Und dann hat das Video halt verarbeitet und sich quasi nach dem Verarbeiten selbst freigeschaltet.
Deswegen hatte das Video auch keinen Titel und keine Videobeschreibung so richtig.
Sondern, sondern halt nur so meine Standard Videobeschreibung, die ich rein mache, dass ich daran denke.
Die Links in die Beschreibung zu kopieren und auf Gameplay-Spieler zu verlinken.
Und der Titel war ja auch einfach nur Cheater.Waff, äh nicht Waff, äh MKV.
Max, wird man in der nahen Zukunft ein Video zu dem Titel machen?
Oder wird man ein Video zum Thema Kryptowährung sehen?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
So Leute, alle wieder da?
Wo gehen sie hin?
Klopause, ja das passt doch.
So Leute, alle wieder am Start?
Wann kommt der Max FPS Coin?
Ich bin eher der Meinung, wir sollten Wubblers Coin machen.
Das klingt viel besser.
Weiter geht's.
Lilly, wo gehen sie hin?
Ich, für kleine Doktoren.
Der hat es aber eilig.
Pures Chaos. Der Aufprall hat alle zueinander geworfen.
Mal sehen.
Kram, kram, kram. Hier ist die Box.
Hermetisch versiegelbare Box erhalten.
Yeah.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch was von dem überfahrenen Eichhörnchen.
Bäh.
Komm, noch mehr reinpacken.
Hehe.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal zurück zum Haus.
Und setzen Johnny, der nur noch einen Tag zu leben hat, ungefähr ein verwestes Eichhörnchen.
Teile von einem verwesten Eichhörnchen aufs Bett.
Wie in echt?
Also Leute, ich denke, das Game dauert noch so ungefähr 45 Minuten.
Und das sind die schlimmsten 45 Minuten.
Es gibt kaum ein Game, was mich emotional so mitgenommen hat wie die letzte Stunde von dem Game.
Hi.
Hast du das überfahrene Tier mitgebracht?
Alles bereit.
Schön.
Dann leg schon mal los.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wo gehst du hin?
Ich...
...
Öffnen Sie bitte das Ventil für etwa drei Sekunden.
Jawohl.
Wurde aber auch Zeit, dass du auftauchst.
Sicher, dass keine Keime entweichen können.
Alles versiegelt und durchgefiltert.
Nicht, dass es einem toten Mann noch viel ausmachen würde.
Sie sollten wissen, dass sich Johnnys Zustand rapide verschlechtert.
Es könnte ihre letzte Chance sein.
Was immer Sie beide da drin vorhaben, ich wünsche Ihnen viel Glück.
Glück ist das Letzte, was wir jetzt brauchen.
Jetzt geht's zur Sache.
Dritter Akt.
Sie senden ihr Licht zu den anderen Leuchttürmen und zu mir.
Wir sind wieder bei Johnny daheim.
Gehen wir.
Ja, hier haben wir aufgehört.
Hol schon mal die Taschentücher raus.
Die letzte Stunde ist wirklich schlimm.
So ein kleines Ding und es macht uns so viel Ärger.
Ich könnte es zum Mond schießen.
Lull.
Schätze, wir können jetzt nur noch das Signal senden und hoffen.
Gut.
Bereit.
Ready.
So, dann stinkt mal Johnny mit dem Eichhörnchen.
Irgendwas passiert.
Schnell, sende es nochmal.
Was ist los?
Da stimmt was nicht.
What?
Übernehmen Sie für mich, Lilly.
Sein Zustand hat sich destabilisiert.
Ich muss die Medikation anpassen.
Was passiert hier?
Er ist instabil geworden.
Raus hier.
Was?
Nein, wir gehen nicht raus.
Raus aus seinem Gedächtnis.
Sofort.
Wieso?
Solange das System so instabil ist,
kann jeder, der sich hier befindet, bleibenden Schaden nehmen.
Du machst Witze.
Warum lockst du dich da nicht aus?
Ich kann nicht, Nal.
Wenn wir uns beide auslocken, ist unsere bisherige Arbeit verloren.
Warum auch immer.
Und wir haben nicht mehr genug Zeit, alles nochmal zu machen, bevor Johnny stirbt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Erzähl mir doch keinen Mist.
Wir sind hier nicht im Kinofilm.
Du bist nicht die Heldin.
Du bist einfach nur bescheuert.
Aber du bist der Held, oder wie?
Mach, dass du rauskommst.
Vergiss es.
Wenn du weg bist, stecken sie mich wahrscheinlich in ein Team mit Alistair.
Alter, ich versteh die Witze von Nal nicht.
Weißt du, wie der Mann stinkt?
Schlimmer als das überfahrene Vieh.
Verdammt, Nal.
Das habe ich nun davon, dass ich dir geholfen habe, dich durch den Eignungstest zu burgeln.
Und, ja, der Doktor, der hat's hingekriegt.
Übrigens, im Nachfolger ist der gleiche Doktor am Start, sieht noch genauso aus und heißt auch einfach nur Doktor.
Alles in Ordnung.
Alles im Griff.
Vorerst.
So, haben wir's geschafft.
Und weißt du was?
Dein Karottenkuchen ist ekelhaft.
Äh.
Ja, und bei der letzten Weihnachtsfeier hattest du...
Komm, lass uns gehen, bevor das nochmal passiert.
Ähm, weißt du, ich hab das nicht wirklich so gemeint.
Also, dass du bescheuert bist.
Ich allerdings schon.
So, gucken wir mal jetzt an, was in Johnnys Kindheit passiert ist.
Ähm.
Ah.
Ich muss zum Ball.
Augen zu und durch.
Wir haben's geschafft.
Wir sind in Johnnys Kindheit.
Es hat funktioniert.
Ich kann es kaum glauben.
Wir sind also tatsächlich durch.
Aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr sicher, ob es mir hier gefallen wird.
Wieso?
Sieht doch alles ganz friedlich aus.
Nein, vorhin in Johnnys Zimmer.
Ist dir da etwas seltsames aufgefallen?
Äh, was denn?
Da war etwas seltsames.
Hast du es nicht gesehen?
Ich, ich glaub nicht.
Schon gut.
Ich hoffe nur, dass ich Unrecht habe.
Wow, das klingt fabelhaft.
Ich weiß.
Okay, irgendwann musst du mal, musst du mich mal da, was?
Irgendwann musst du sie mal dorthin mitnehmen.
Ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Ich bin fail.
Die Zeitüberlappung gerät außer Kontrolle.
Sieh dir mal an, wie viele Exemplare von ihm hier sind.
Es ist ein regelrechter Johnny-Zoo.
Äh, ha.
Da ist der Ball.
Johnny, bleibst du stehen?
Ja.
Guck mal, ein Eichhörnchen.
Sieh mal auf die Uhr.
Wir sind so spät dran.
Ich mach mich besser auf den Weg.
Das Geschäft macht heute früher zu.
Äh, pass auf dich auf.
Grüß die Jungs von mir.
Mach ich.
Wir sehen uns.
Tja, das ist wohl eine Sackgasse.
Und worauf wolltest du hinaus?
Vergiss es einfach.
Vielleicht hatte ich auch mal Unrecht.
Schau nur, dieser Ort.
Er ist so friedlich.
In dieser Erinnerung existiert nichts, was so etwas auslösen könnte.
Außer, verdammt.
Wir müssen umkehren, sofort.
Moment mal, was denn jetzt schon wieder?
Halt einfach die Klappe, komm mit.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Er war bewusstlos.
Wie können wir das hier sehen, wenn er es selbst nicht einmal gesehen hat?
Jedenfalls ist es ein Wunder, dass er überlebt hat.
Eigentlich hat er das ja auch gar nicht.
Äh, wie kann Johnny das nicht überlebt haben? Er ist ja noch da.
Hast du dir sein Zimmer nicht angesehen, Niall?
Johnny hatte ein Etagenbett.
Joey!
Joey, kannst du mich hören?
Deswegen nennt ihn seine Mutter auch immer Joey.
Joey.
Warum hast du Joey überfahren, Mama?
Ach, das ist auch noch die Mutter.
Das habe ich beim ersten Mal durchspielen gar nicht gecheckt.
Das ist die Mutter von ihm auch noch.
Jetzt ergibt es ja noch mehr Sinn, dass die Mutter ihn jetzt Joey nennt.
Warum hast du ihn überfahren?
Wach auf, Joey.
Geht der Chat noch oder seid ihr alle so gespannt dabei und sagt nichts?
Auch wenn sie noch so klein waren.
Ein Zwillingsbruder zu verlieren.
Ganz davon abgesehen, wie sich die Mutter fühlen musste.
Ups.
Wenigstens hatte Johnny die Beta-Blocker, um die Erinnerung auszulöschen.
Nicht, dass da noch viel wäre.
Sie sind nur entkoppelt nicht gelöscht.
Irgendwo hier drin hat ein Nachhall dieser Erinnerung wahrscheinlich weiter existiert.
Wir wissen übrigens immer noch nicht, warum er zum Mond will.
Was ist mit der Mutter?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie Beta-Blocker genommen hat.
Sieht aus, als wäre sie ein wenig durchgedreht.
Zumindest glaube ich nicht mehr, dass Joey nur ihr Spitzname für Johnny war.
Aber wenn sie Johnny als Ersatz für Joey nimmt, was ist dann mit Johnny selbst?
Mir gefällt das hier nicht. Lass uns gehen.
Das ist nicht die einzige abgekoppelte Erinnerung.
Seltsam. Es baut keine Barriere mehr auf.
Mal nicht den Teufel an die Wand.
Kleiner Johnny und Joey.
Mann, das musst du unbedingt auch mal lesen.
Ich meine echt jetzt, diese Serie ist einfach nur genial.
Ich habe schon drei Bücher einfach so weggelesen.
Johnny, was liest du denn?
Animorphs.
Ja, das fand Johnny später auch geil.
Es geht um eine Gruppe von Kindern, die sich in Tiere verwandeln und gegen Schnecken kämpfen, die deine Gedanken kontrollieren.
Klingt nach einer tollen Story.
Ach, diese seltsamen Alien-Zeugs ist nichts für mich.
Wieso nicht? Es ist der Hammer.
Statt nur langweilig... Guckt euch mal übrigens den Rucksack an. Den hat er später immer noch.
Statt zur langweiligen Schule zu gehen, könnten sie Tiger werden.
Die großen Bösen.
Die bösen Aliens in Stücke reißen.
Dabei machen sie immer so... Ich mach das jetzt mal nicht nach. So wie Tiger halt machen, wenn man das schreibt.
Und dann kriegen sie Laser.
Und dann schon Terrors.
Lass das, Lull.
eins Tages werde ich ein berühmter Autor.
Dann schreibe ich die coolste Geschichte überhaupt.
Und alle Kinder kriegen mein Buch umsonst.
Ich werde uns reich machen
Und dann kaufe ich dir und Mama eine dicke Villa.
Wie willst du uns reich machen, wenn die Bücher auch umsonst sind?
Umsonst für die Kinder. Die Eltern müssen zahlen, das ist doch klar.
Klar, ich bin ganz sicher, dass die Eltern dir das Geld hinterher schmeißen werden.
Was ist? Bist du immer noch sauer wegen neulich?
Jetzt komm schon. Ich habe als erster gesagt, dass ich den Zug haben will.
Es war alles ganz fair.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Preis passiert?
Äh, was ist eigentlich mit deinem Preis passiert?
Habe ich verschenkt.
An einen Penner.
Pass auf, es geht nicht nur um neulich.
Du weißt, dass du immer Mamas Liebling warst.
Hey, das ist doch gar nicht wahr.
Erinnerst du dich an letzte Weihnachten?
Und letzte Ostern und als wir angeln waren und und und?
Okay, äh, weißt du was? Du kannst meinen Zug haben, wenn du willst.
Ey, echt jetzt?
Ja, hier, nehme den Zug.
Ich meine, nach deiner Logik wird sie mir ja einfach einen neuen kaufen, oder?
Hör mal, Johnny.
Welchen Unterschied macht es schon, wem von uns was gehört?
Alles was meinst, ist auch deins.
Ich meine, wir können doch beide da mitspielen, oder?
Stimmt.
Siehst du?
Ich meine, du bist mein Zwillingsbruder, Mann.
Alter, Lan.
Du bist wie ein Teil von mir.
Ey, komm, lass uns die Nachbarn ärgern.
Warte mal, im Regen?
Klar, auf geht's.
Animorphs.
Nicht genug Memory-Links?
Doch, klar.
So, und jetzt werden wir langsam verstehen, was Sache ist.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das ist somit die Schlüssel-Szene in dem Game.
So eine Art Jahrmarkt, oder nicht?
Sollen wir uns ein wenig umsehen?
Wie wäre es, wenn ich mich umsehe und du hier einfach stehen bleibst?
Wie wäre es, wenn wir uns eine Stunde lang nur noch in Frageform unterhalten,
hör auf zu quatschen und geh?
Jetzt hast du es vermasselt.
Tomaten sind keine Früchte.
Na, haben sie auch eingelegte Gurken?
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht wissen, was Tomaten sind.
Kleiner Johnny und kleiner Joey.
Aber ich will dieses blöde Ding nicht.
Ich will den Zug.
Wir haben nur noch einen Zug.
Willst du deinen Preis vielleicht stattdessen gegen einen Teddybär tauschen?
Nein, ich will den Zug.
Na, kommt schon.
Johnny, mach keine Szene.
Joey hat ihn zuerst gewonnen, fair und gerecht, oder etwa nicht?
Aber ich habe auch gewonnen, nur weil er vor mir dran war.
Lull.
Ist schon okay, du darfst auch da mitspielen.
Siehst du, wie nett von deinem Bruder Johnny.
Aber ich will den Zug.
Okay, ihr Hefe-Klöße, blockiert mal nicht den ganzen Stand.
Komm, wir schauen mal, was es da drüben gibt.
Ich bin kein Hefe-Kloß.
Weißt du was, ab jetzt nenne ich dich nur noch Hefe-Klößchen.
Verarsch mich nicht.
Ah ja, das Schicksal hält wohl eine volle Fügung für euch bereit.
Aus diesem hier könnt ihr Anwalt werden und aus diesem hier ein Arzt.
Etf.
Kommt ihr zwei, ich kauf euch Süßigkeiten.
Hey, wo ist mein Trinkgeld?
Fuh.
Äh.
Wo ist Johnny hin?
Dafuq?
Wo ist er hin?
Ah, hier.
Es werden drei Memory-Links benötigt.
Okay, äh.
Ich hab sie übersehen, wo sind sie denn?
Äh.
Bin ich blind?
Ah, hier runter.
Was?
Dafuq?
Moment.
Hä?
Was übersehe ich denn jetzt gerade?
Klopft den was?
Klopft den Maulwurf.
Ist das nicht Tierquälerei?
Das sind ja auch keine echten Maulwürfe.
Genau.
So haben die Leute Dampf abgelassen, bevor Ego-Shooter erfunden wurden.
Wie primitiv.
Ganz schön Ghetto, Alter.
Wo hast du davon gelesen?
Mein Opa war ein Fan davon.
Wollen sie ein Spielchen wagen?
Einfach alle Köpfe klopfen und tolle Preise gewinnen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Oh nein.
Äh.
WTF?
Nein.
Ich will nicht Hammer spielen.
Äh.
Hallo?
Oh nee.
Was?
Zum Teufel.
Mit dem Steuer...
Ach du Scheiß.
Was ist das für eine dämliche Steuerung?
Ich muss das mit der Maus machen und nicht mit der Tastatur.
Ist das denn total hängen geblieben, das Ding?
Mit der Tastatur?
Ich kann das nicht mit der Maus steuern.
Das ist ja Fail.
Kann ich ja gar nicht mein krasses Flick-Aim verwenden.
Das ist ja anstrengend.
Und die Steuerung ist übelst ungenau.
Okay.
Zeit ist um.
Easy.
Reicht.
Das ergibt 61%.
Das ist ein neuer Rekord.
Wat?
Okay.
Oh nee.
Dafür gab es Memory Link.
Ich musste das also machen.
Okay.
Gut.
Gut zu wissen.
Nein.
Was muss ich denn machen?
Die Steuerung hast du gewählt.
Ja.
Okay.
Stimmt.
Ich habe einfach Escape gedrückt.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich drei Memory Links?
Ich habe zwei Memory Links.
Okay.
Ein Memory Link fehlt noch.
Sag mal.
Bin ich irgendwie blind oder was?
Moment.
Wo muss ich denn hier jetzt was machen?
Mit dem Typ habe ich doch schon geredet.
Ach.
Hier unten.
Willkommen.
Ich präsentiere das kleinste Riesenrad der Welt.
Ja.
Ist sehr groß.
Können wir eine Probefahrt machen?
Natürlich nicht.
Funktioniert das überhaupt?
Einfach ein paar Stühle dran geklebt.
Ja.
Es sieht nicht wirklich aus wie ein Riesenrad.
Okay.
Weiter geht's.
Wir haben drei Memory Links.
Wobei.
Gehen wir jetzt da lang?
Oder gehen wir da lang?
Ich könnte wenden.
Das macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Wir gehen jetzt hier lang.
Weil in die Richtung sind sie auch gelaufen.
Ja.
Was gibt es hier?
Kleiner Joey.
Kleiner Johnny.
Hapa.
Könntest du wenigstens eine probieren, Johnny
Wer weiß, vielleicht kommst du damit auch auf den Geschmack
Genau
Äh
Nee
Ich bin fertig, Mama
Kann ich spielen gehen?
Okay, aber nur auf dem Spielplatz
Nicht einen Meter weiter
Gib mir die Tasche
Ich pass für dich darauf auf
Nein, das ist meins
Hab ich gewonnen
Eingelegte Oliven
Gehen wir mal Johnny hinterher
Fünf Memorings
Okay, ich muss noch irgendwas anklicken
Was muss ich anklicken?
Äh
Was gibt's denn hier noch?
Was muss ich denn hier noch machen?
Das glitzert so
Da muss ich doch bestimmt hin
Oder was ist hier?
Ah, ich hab's
Easy
Einfach langlaufen
Okay, gehen wir mal Joey hinterher
Äh, Johnny
Jetzt bring ich auch schon einmal durch
Da steht er, ja
Wo geht der hin?
Er darf doch nur auf den Spielplatz
Aber
Aber natürlich hört er wieder auf seine Mutter nicht
Aber er macht das in dem Alter schon
Auf einmal hören wir nicht so gut was
Will er dann hin?
Wow
Ja, da hat der Sibaro recht
Wir werden gleich erfahren, warum Johnny zum Mond will
Okay, er hat den Weg
Äh, okay
Er hat den Weg verlassen und einen coolen Ort gefunden
Aber seien wir ehrlich
Er hätte ebenso gut von einem Rudel-Tiger angefallen werden können
Tiger leben nicht in Rudeln
Das war auch nur eine Redensart
Weißt du, als ich noch klein war, hat mich mein Opa jedes Jahr zum Sterngucken mitgenommen
Ja
Es gab einen Hügel außerhalb der Stadt, wo wir immer standen
Derselbe Hügel, jedes Jahr
Wir schauen
Was, Little Samso, mir fällt gerade erst mal auf, dass du den Hintergrund hier aus dem Spiel hast
Nee, hab ich nicht
Ich hab nur den Hintergrund mit Mond und Stern gesucht
Wir schauen in die Sterne, bis der Morgen dämmerte
Nun ja, ich schau dir das an
Nee, ich schau dir das an
Ich bin sehr frisch
Du bist talkative
Du bistا
Du bista
Dann schau das, der Bein
Nein, die Beine
Ich weiß nicht, warum du mich nicht anschaust
Wie warst du heute morgens?
Letztes Wochenende
Ich war und schaute am Tag
Und da war ich schon wach
Und ich schaute nachts
Ich hab das Telekop vor und ich hab mich nicht mehr getauscht
Ich hab noch nie getauscht
Ich hab keine Atmosphäre
Ich hab nichts getauscht
Ich hab nur einen Schmerz
Und ich hab das Telekop, mein Jungfrau
Der hat mich nur das Telekop für mich getragen
Natürlich
Nun hätte Mama mir allerdings niemals erlaubt, die ganze Nacht wach zu bleiben
Wie ich in die Koffeinsucht abdriftete.
Du bist ein Monstrum.
Ich weiß.
Es ist schon sehr traurig.
All diese schöne Erinnerungen verloren und niemals wiedergefunden.
Und wer weiß, wie viele mehr es noch gibt.
Tja, wie du immer sagst, man muss jeden Moment für sich genießen, nicht?
Jo.
Hä?
WTF?
Ich hab dir doch gesagt, hier gibt's Tigerrudel.
Es ist die kleine River.
Daran sieht man, Johnny und River kannten sich schon lange vor der Schule.
Johnny weiß es bloß nicht mehr.
Allerdings River weiß es noch.
Warte, bleib hier.
Ich bin Johnny. Und wie heißt du?
Du bist an meinem Platz.
Was? Dein Platz?
Äh, tut mir leid, ich wollte mich hier nicht ganz alleine ausbreiten.
Äh, willst du dich zu mir setzen?
Bist du hier, um die Sterne zu beobachten?
Äh.
Und du?
Schau nur.
Wusstest du, dass es so viele Lichter am Himmel gibt?
Jo.
Äh, ihr wusst ich, ich wusste das auch.
Das ist also dein Platz, ja?
Nur während des Jahrmagens.
Kein Fan von Menschenmengen bin ich auch nicht.
Weißt du, du hast mir immer noch nicht deinen Namen gesagt.
Ich sag ihn dir auch nicht.
In der Schule machen sich alle darüber lustig.
Warum?
Sie sagen, dass...
Sie sagen, dass sie aufs Klo müssen, wenn sie an ihn denken.
Äh, aha.
Ja, dann sag ihn mir halt nicht.
Tja, es kann doch eigentlich nichts schlimmer als John sein.
Ich meine, überall auf der Welt heißt fast jeder John.
Auch in Indien?
Das wird mich nicht wundern.
Was ist denn verkehrt daran?
Hä?
Was ist verkehrt daran, einen Namen zu haben, den jeder hat?
Äh, es ist langweilig, denke ich.
Ich meine, wenn alle so heißen, wo ist denn der Sinn?
Ich hätte nichts dagegen.
Ausnahmsweise mal, den gleichen Namen zu haben, den alle anderen auch haben.
Das ist wie mit diesen Lichtern am Himmel.
Von hier unten sehen sie alle gleich aus, aber das macht den einzelnen Stern kein bisschen weniger.
Ja, vielleicht...
Diese ganzen Sterne da oben, was glaubst du, sind sie?
Mein Vater sagt, sie sind riesige brennende Kugeln aus Gas.
Da hat er recht.
Ach, das denkt er sich doch nur aus.
Warum sollte er mich dann anlügen?
Weil, äh, das machen Erwachsene halt.
Die denken sich komische Sachen aus.
Den Weihnachtsbahn, der Osterhase, Kängurus, so Zeug halt.
Hast du schon mal versucht, den Osterhase zu kennen?
Den Osterhasen aus Sternen zu machen?
Meinst du, wie ein Sternbild?
Ja.
Ähm, andere Sachen schon, aber noch nie einen Hase.
Möchtest du einen machen?
Klar machen wir das beste Sternbild aller Zeiten.
Mal sehen, wer zuerst eins hat.
Okay.
Von drei.
Drei, zwei, eins und los.
Ich seh's.
Tja, River ist schnell mit.
So was.
Hä?
Was, wie?
So schnell?
Am Himmel.
Wo genau am Himmel?
Denk in großen Zusammenhängen, Johnny.
Ähm.
Größer als all die anderen es tun.
Ich, hä?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Moment mal.
Wart mal.
Ich seh's.
Sag mir, was du siehst.
Da drüben, stimmt's?
Das sind die zwei Löffel und der Kopf.
Und weiter?
Da sind seine Füße.
Äh, und was noch?
Ihr merkt schon, sie fragt ihn genau das gleiche wie bei den Papierhasen, ne?
Und der Mond.
Und der Mond ist ein großer Runterbauch.
Wir wissen aber immer noch nicht, warum Johnny auf den Mond will.
Aber ich glaub, dass du in zwei, drei Dialogboxen erfahren wirst.
Also, was glaubst du, sind sie wirklich?
Die Sterne, meine ich.
Ich...
Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es noch nie jemandem erzählt, aber...
Ich habe immer gedacht, dass sie Leuchttürme sind.
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die festsitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels.
Wow, muss ganz schön was los sein da oben.
Ist aber nicht so.
Sie können all die anderen Leuchttürme dort draußen sehen und sie wollen mit ihnen reden.
Aber das können sie nicht, denn sie sind alle viel zu weit voneinander entfernt, um zu hören, was die anderen sagen.
Sie können nichts tun, außer aus der Ferne ihr Licht schieben.
Sie können nichts tun, außer aus der Ferne ihr Licht schicken.
Also tun sie das.
Sie senden ihr Licht zu den anderen Leuchttürmen und zu mir.
Warum zu dir?
Weil ich eines Tages mit einem von ihnen Freundschaft schließen werde.
Das wissen wir ja, mit Anja später.
Deine Tasche, was ist da drin?
Äh, der Preis, den ich bei Klopp den Maulwurf gewonnen habe.
Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich habe es versucht, aber ich bin zu ungeschickt dafür.
Was hast du gespielt?
Ich habe es nicht gekriegt.
Es ist ein Ding.
Ich kann nicht wirklich sagen, was es ist.
So eine Art Entenbieber-Ding.
Darf ich mal sehen?
Es sieht so seltsam aus.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte auch eins gewinnen.
Johnny, wo steckst du denn?
Mama ruft mich, ich muss weg.
Hier, nimm es wieder.
Weißt du was, behalt es, es gehört dir.
Mir?
Ja.
Ich will ja nicht angeben, aber ich bin einfach der Beste bei diesem Spiel.
Bist du nächstes Jahr wieder hier?
Ja, du auch?
Klar.
Selber Ort, selbe Zeit.
Ja.
Und wenn du es vergisst oder wir uns aus den Augen verlieren?
Ich habe jetzt mal nichts gesagt.
Das ist der Grund, warum Johnny auf den Mond will.
Und er kann sich nicht daran erinnern.
Weil er komische Medikamente nehmen musste.
Und seine Mutter hat versucht, ihn zu Joey umzuerziehen.
Und deswegen wollte er in der Schule auch mit River zusammen sein.
Weil er die ganze Zeit jemand anderes sein sollte.
Aber eigentlich wollte er nur er sein.
Dann treffen wir uns auf dem Mond wieder, Dummerchen.
Auf dem Bauch des Hasen.
Erinnert euch noch daran, dass River Johnny einen dicken Hasen gebastelt hat aus dem Papier?
Das ergibt jetzt alles Sinn, oder?
Sie wollte ihm das die ganze Zeit erzählen, dass er sich daran erinnert.
Aber er hat es halt nicht mal gecheckt.
Johnny.
Ich bin schon unterwegs.
Mein Hacky-Sack ist noch in der Tasche.
Du sagst es, du bist ungestickt, stimmt's?
Versuch es damit.
Falls sie sich jemals aus den Augen verlieren.
Moment mal, soll das heißen?
Sag mir nicht, du hast das nicht kommen sehen.
Und ich hatte schon geglaubt, dass hier würde eine inspirierende Kindheitstrauma-Geschichte werden.
Ich hätte wissen sollen.
Dass irgendein Mädchen auftaucht und ein Schmachtfetzen daraus macht.
Ich glaube, wir wissen jetzt, was wir tun müssen, um ihn zum Mond zu bringen.
Moment mal, du willst doch nicht etwa das wirklich tun, oder?
Es ist unser Job, Neil.
Nein.
So lautet unser Auftrag.
Verdammt nochmal, Eva. Nein, das kannst du nicht machen.
Eva, ich weiß, dass du hier irgendwo bist.
Wo hat sich Eva versteckt?
Da ist sie.
Umdrehen.
Nein, ich weiß, was du vorhast.
Ich weiß, dass du das weißt.
Ja, und nun, ich weiß, dass du weißt, dass ich weiß.
Hör mal, unser Job ist, ihn zum Mond zu bringen.
Und das wird nur dann passieren, wenn Johnny motiviert ist, dieses Ziel zu verfolgen.
Aber wenn wir dafür River entfernen müssen, was soll die Sache dann überhaupt noch bringen?
Er will überhaupt nur deshalb zum Mond, weil sie gestorben ist.
Das ist ihm quasi in dem Moment, wo seine Frau gestorben ist, wieder eingefallen.
Unterbewusst. Er wusste das ja nicht mehr.
Wir sind gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet, diesen Vertrag zu erfüllen.
Scheiß auf den Vertrag.
Ich habe diesen Job nicht angenommen, um ihm die Lebensfreude zu nehmen, Eva.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie du das siehst.
Aber ich mache das hier, damit der alte Knacker mit einem Lächeln im Gesicht sterben kann.
Ich doch auch. Und ich mag meinen Job.
Aber wenn wir gegen unsere gesetzlichen Pflichten verstoßen, sehen wir uns vor Gericht wieder.
Ja, das werden wir anfechten.
Wir wissen, dass Johnny glücklicher wird, wenn er nicht zum Mond fliegt.
Es gibt viele alternative Lebenstangenten, denen Johnny glücklicher wäre, naja.
Wir sind nicht hier, um Gott zu spielen.
Es ist unser Job, ihm zu geben, was er bestellt hat.
Zufällig wissen wir aber, was er will. Besser als er selbst.
Versteh doch. Ich riskiere River doch nur deswegen, weil ich an sie glaube.
Und was soll das heißen, du riskierst sie? Du entfernst sie.
Außerdem werde ich es wiedergutmachen.
Wiedergutmachen?
Ja.
Wie denn?
Uns läuft die Zeit davon, Al.
Vertrau mir einfach.
Sagt die Frau, die mich von dem scheiß Leuchtturm geschubst hat.
Verdammte Lichtwerte.
Mit deinen Krummton schaltest du meinen Zugriff nicht vollständig ab, Eva.
Versteckte Fallen, wirklich?
Ich versuche nur Zeit zu gewinnen.
Danke, dass du Bescheid sagst.
Bewegen.
Im Prinzip kann dir in dem Game nichts passieren.
Das ist ziemlich teure Ausrüstung, die du hier durch die Gegend wirfst.
Ich meine es ernst. Bleib einfach, wo du bist und warte, bis ich fertig bin.
Ach, du kannst mich mal, ähm, sonst wo.
Hier ist nix.
Hör mal, zwing mich nicht dazu, hier auszusteigen und dir den Stecker zu ziehen.
Du würdest ernsthaft riskieren, dass deine Erinnerungen in diesem kaputten Zustand bleiben?
Hör einfach auf, bitte. Ich brauch nicht lang.
Oh, nicht schon wieder.
Oder komm doch und hol mich. Ich bin am Ende des Flurs.
Das meinst du doch nicht ernst.
Findest du das witzig, Eva?
Das sind nicht einfach nur Zombie-Evas.
Das sind Zombie-Fas.
Kein Schritt näher, ich bin bewaffnet.
Was, WASD benutzen?
Ah, okay.
Alter, die Steuerung, die Steuerung!
Die Steuerung ist so fail!
Also sind die Dinger doch sowas gut.
ETF?
Alter!
Das ist alles nur eine Schleife.
Muss ich vielleicht hier runter?
Oh, scheiß drauf.
ETF?
Eva, was ist passiert?
Äh, Eva?
Das ergibt ja alles keinen Sinn mehr hier drinnen jetzt.
Ich hab immer gedacht, dass sie Leuchttürme sind.
Das ganze System versinkt im Chaos.
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die fest sitzt am anderen Ende des Himmels.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr jetzt.
Es wird ihnen helfen, den Zustand ihrer Partnerin zu verstehen. Lieber nicht. Warum das?
Das kennen wir ja alles.
Bloß, dass es nicht so gewesen ist, wie sie jetzt aussieht.
Fuck.
Zumindest Johnny geht es auch nicht sonderlich gut gerade.
Hallo?
Bleib hier.
Ich bin Johnny und wie heißt du?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr.
Das ist jetzt wie beim Matrix, ein Telefon.
Hallo?
Nein?
Morpheus?
Oh Mann.
Was hier ist Eva, du Trottel?
Kein Scheiß, wir sind die einzigen hier.
Eva, was auch immer du gerade tust, hör auf damit.
Wir wissen vielleicht nicht, was Johnny will, aber wir wissen genau, was er nicht will.
Und genau das beschwörst du gerade herauf.
Es ist bereits geschehen.
Warum kommst du da nicht endlich raus?
Da ist sie ja.
Oliver ist weg.
Was hast du mit ihr gemacht?
Entspann dich. Sie geht nur woanders hin.
Weißt du, es ist eine Sache, meinen Zugriff zu blockieren, um mich mit ein paar Oliven zu füttern.
Aber das hier ist jenseits von gut und böse. Es tut mir leid, aber das hier führt zu gar nichts, wenn du weiter die Erinnerungen zurücksetzt.
Aber jetzt ist der einzige Weg, du musst mir vertrauen.
Also bitte, beruhig dich einfach und warte hier.
Dann los jetzt, auslösen.
Wo willst du denn noch hin?
Es gibt noch eine allerletzte Sache, die ich erledigen muss.
Du kleine Poserin, es gibt doch gar keinen Grund, ein Tor zu visualisieren.
Was soll eigentlich dieses Melodrama, Niall?
Warum kämpfst du so hart darum, dass ich...
Fuck, jetzt habe ich es übersprungen.
Für das hier.
Vergiss es, wir haben keine Zeit.
Nick, das wird schon mal. Dreh dich einfach um.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Ja, Johnny will sie ansprechen und River ist weg.
Aber das Treffen zwischen Johnny und River auf dem Jahrmarkt, das wurde nicht gelöscht.
Das erste, wo sie anscheinend anfangen, das Ganze zu löschen, ist, als Johnny River in der Schule wieder getroffen hat.
Und sich nicht mehr daran erinnern konnte, dass er sie schon kennt.
Sie ist weg.
Sorry, Kleiner.
Jetzt gibt es kein Zurück mehr.
Das Game geht noch ungefähr 10-15 Minuten.
Los jetzt, sonst sind alle guten Tische besetzt.
Die sind alle gleich, Gutmensch.
Johnny, nein, Joey hat recht.
An denen in der Nähe der Küche liegt es besser.
Guck mal, sein Bruder lebt wieder.
Zumindest, so wie er sich das Ganze einbildet.
Ganz genau.
Und man muss sich nur umdrehen, um einen Oliven-Nachschlag zu kriegen.
Oliven.
Ihn zu retten, rechtfertigt gar nichts.
Er kann sich immer eine neue River suchen, Niall.
Aber seinen Bruder gibt es nur einmal.
Jetzt komm, wir stehen im Weg.
Und weg ist River.
Die, die das singt, ist die Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies.
Und du, Johnny?
Johnny will Astronaut werden.
Warum will Johnny Astronaut werden?
Weil er jetzt früher schon gemerkt hat, dass er River sehen will.
Ohne, dass es ihm so richtig klar ist.
Jetzt Outernick im Liegestützen machen.
Und da ist er bei der NASA.
Und will Astronaut werden.
Genau das, wie es sein soll.
Wie er sich das gewünscht hat.
Nur, dass River weg ist.
Ich glaube, ihm das jetzt wirklich so viel lieber ist.
Habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Er hat es also wirklich geschafft, was?
Du klingst überrascht.
Was ist aus? Wir machen jeden Kunden glücklich.
Denn wir sind einfach der Wahnsinn geworden.
Das hier ist kein Erfolg.
Ach komm, freu dich doch.
Wir sind hier bei der NASA.
Wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Lass uns wenigstens ein bisschen umschauen.
Gut, viel gibt es da nicht zum Umschauen.
Super, ich meine, jetzt bekommt Johnny...
...zwar seinen Wunsch erfüllt, zum Mond zu fliegen.
Er wird aber nie wissen, warum er es eigentlich will.
Und River ist auch weg.
Kein Haus, keine Leuchttürme.
Bitte warten Sie hier.
Es wird gleich jemand kommen, der Sie herumführt.
Wie armselig, dieses ganze Theater nur wegen einem Mädchen.
Ich finde das lustig, wie sie die Rollen jetzt vertauscht haben.
Vorher hat Niall die ganze Zeit so Sprüche gemacht.
Ich wusste, dass du das jetzt sagen würdest.
Wie armselig, dieses ganze Theater nur wegen eines Mädchens.
Na endlich, schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Ja, ja.
To the Moon.
Die Geschichte eines Versagers, der Astronaut werden wollte.
Ein Roman von Joey Wiles.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass jemand sich diesen Schuld kaufen würde.
Wir sind ja nicht in der wirklichen Welt, Niall.
Was gibt es denn hier sonst noch?
Tja, Michael, das ist die große Frage, ne?
Ob das wirklich so ist?
Ob das Johnny nun so viel lieber ist?
Weiß man nicht.
Vier Memory Links.
Wieso hat Johnny nochmal sein Gedächtnis verloren?
Weil er Medikamente genommen hat, als er jung war.
Oder besser gesagt, ihm wahrscheinlich seine Mutter die Medikamente verabreicht hat,
nachdem sie ein bisschen durchgedreht ist,
weil sie ihr eigenes Kind überfahren hat.
Was man auch nachvollziehen kann.
Und dann hat sie sich halt gedacht, die Mutter von Johnny,
hey, dann lass uns mal Johnny quasi umerziehen zu Joey,
den sie überfahren hat.
Und dann hat Johnny irgendwelche Medikamente verabreicht,
dass er sich an nichts mehr erinnert.
Ähm, liegt das an mir oder ist der Aufzug innen kleiner als außen?
Also man muss sagen, die Geschichte ist wirklich gut durchdacht.
Vor allem, es gibt alles Sinn.
Am Shuttle wird zur Zeit mit Hochdruck gearbeitet.
Wir können uns im Moment nur von hier aus ansehen.
Hier nicht.
Was ist nicht hier?
Das Shuttle, yeah.
Wow.
Das kannst du laut sagen.
Weißt du, was am eindrucksvollsten ist?
Was denn?
Das Stück ganz oben oder das untere Ende des Shuttles.
Da muss ich dir zustimmen.
Und wie ich die armen Seelen bemitleide, die diese Details nicht ansehen können.
In der Tat.
Besonders die Nase da oben.
Ja, wir sehen es nicht.
Wenn die Arbeiten abgeschlossen sind, wird es wohl nicht mehr so wie jetzt aussehen.
Jetzt ist die einzige Gelegenheit.
Der F...
Sag mal, was meinst du?
War die Mondladung im letzten Jahrhundert wirk...
Fang nicht damit an.
Nein, fang gar nicht das an.
Wo waren wir hier? Gehen wir da hin.
Das ist die Zentrifuge.
Wenn sie Glück haben, werden sie eines Tages lernen, sie zu hassen.
Äh, genau. Schleuderdings.
Hier ist auch nichts.
Wovon redest du, Eva?
Komm, wir haben nicht mehr lange.
Johnny geht's nicht gut.
Ja, Hero LP, das...
Also, was du hier jetzt siehst, das ist ja nur im Kopf von Johnny.
Das war ja in Wirklichkeit nicht so.
Es hat sich an dem, wie es wirklich war, ja nichts geändert.
Johnny denkt einfach nur, es ist so gelaufen.
Und ob das jetzt besser ist, wie das, wie es in echt passiert ist...
Das ist eine Frage, mit der sich das Nachfolgerspiel Finding Paradise...
...intensiv beschäftigt.
Quasi...
Braucht man den ganzen Scheiß hier überhaupt?
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir irgendwann auch nochmal Finding Paradise spielen.
Das ist nicht ganz so traurig.
Ich hoffe, bei der echten NASA haben sie größere Aufzüge.
Das ist das Missionskontrollzentrum.
Journey Stream.
Journey? Das auf der PS3?
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Im Moment passiert hier nicht viel, aber eines Tages werden sie es in Aktion erleben.
Ich habe beinahe erwartet, dass Zordon auf dem Bildschirm auftaucht.
Oh Gott, nein ey.
Das ist nicht gut.
Gehen wir wieder nach unten.
Du musst wirklich mal an deiner Kommunikationsfähigkeit arbeiten. Eva, was willst du überhaupt?
Lass uns gehen.
So, jetzt dürfen wir hier rein.
Ich frage mich, ob die echte NASA wirklich so aussieht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist ein Konstrukt aus Johnnys Fantasie.
Ah ja, Wikifakten.
Vergleistert mit seinen Hirngespinsten.
Trotzdem merkwürdig. Vögel zu hören, aber keine zu sehen.
Sorry, Niall.
Ich dachte wirklich, wir hätten eine gute Chance.
Hä? Was?
Und hier ist der Pauseraum.
Das ist David. Er ist unser Missionsspezialist.
Freut mich, Sie kennenzulernen.
Zumindest hat er es in die NASA geschafft, so wie es aussieht.
Meinst du, er hat es bis zum Ende durchgehalten?
Selbst wenn.
Es braucht mehr als das, um Astronaut zu werden.
Dann lass uns schnell den letzten Memory-Link finden.
Ich würde ungern das Finale verpassen.
Was ist los?
Ist es schon zu spät?
Ich weiß nicht.
Und hier ist unser anderer Neuzugang.
River, richtig?
Schön, Sie dabei zu haben.
Hallo, ich bin John.
Das war aber knapp.
Was zum Teufel, Eva?
Du hast sie doch gelöscht.
Nein, ich habe sie nicht gelöscht. Wie ich schon sagte, ich habe sie nur verschoben.
Was sie mit ihrem Leben anfängt, ist ihre Sache.
Aber diese Welt besteht aus öffentlichen Daten und Johnnys Fantasie.
Und weil Rivers persönliche Daten nicht Teil der öffentlichen Quellen sind, kommt das hier alles von Johnny.
Trotzdem gab es nur eine gewisse Chance.
Wie konntest du sicher sein, dass es funktionieren würde?
Ich war mir nicht sicher.
Das hätte ganz schön schief gehen können, das ist dir klar, oder?
Du warst noch nie sehr risikofreudig, Niall.
Einigen wir uns einfach darauf, dass diese Runde an mich geht.
Wir haben doch noch zwei Helme, oder?
Ich glaube, Johnny wird sich über ein bisschen Gesellschaft freuen.
Wie es scheint, hat er es selbst geschrieben.
Ganz schön eintönig, wenn du mich fragst.
Wie heißt es?
To the Moon.
Das ist ein schöner Titel.
Ja, da seid ihr ja.
Ihr zwei solltet euch ausruhen. Morgen ist der große Tag.
Morgen geht's zum Mond.
Ich will auch ausruhen werden.
Eines Tages, mein Sohn. Wirst du das vielleicht?
Lull.
Hättest du gedacht, dass sie es schaffen würden?
Du etwa?
Nein, hätte ich nicht.
So wie sie ist, hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten, dass sie es schafft.
Aber da lag ich wohl falsch.
Umso besser, oder?
Ja, ich freue mich für sie.
Joey, weißt du, das ist mein Bruder da in diesem Shuttle?
Krass.
Ja, ich habe darüber mal ein Buch geschrieben.
Allerdings mit einem weniger optimistischen Ende.
Da muss ich wohl noch mal ran.
Komm mal, Lilly und der Doktor.
Hey, Doktor Watson, nicht wahr?
Danke, dass Sie uns hier reingelassen haben.
Ja, schon gut, Eva.
Ja, schon gut, Eva hat das geregelt.
Haben Sie herausgefunden, weshalb er zum Mond wollte?
Natürlich.
Und, was haben Sie alles gesehen?
Sagen wir so, das Ganze war ein Haufen schmalziger Käse, der sich dann von selbst gelöst hat.
Wissen Sie, letzte Nacht habe ich mehrmals gedacht, dass wir Johnny bereits verloren hätten.
Ich denke, dass er am Leben festhält, um auf sie beide zu warten.
Dann hat er ganz schön viel Geduld.
Ich hoffe nur, dass sich das Warten lohnt.
Machen Sie schon weiter, Ihre Kollegin wartet.
Ich dachte, von hier wäre die Aussicht ganz gut.
Zumindest gut genug, um den Verkehr zu sperren, ha?
Sicher, sogar dann, wenn die beiden real wären.
Tja, das ist jetzt wohl der Augenblick, für den wir so lange gearbeitet haben.
Bereit für den Start?
Start freigeben.
Komm rauf.
Äh, warum?
Warum nicht?
Du willst mich nur wieder runterschmeißen, oder?
Kann schon sein.
Aber die Aussicht ist das Risiko wert.
Aufkommen, Niall.
Hoch.
Na, komm.
Auf geht's.
Ja, das war To The Moon.
Und ich habe euch nicht zu viel versprochen, dass am Ende alles zusammenpasst, oder?
Also, ich muss sagen, von dem, wie das geschrieben ist, habe ich selten in einem Game was Besseres gesehen.
Und ich hatte selten bei einem Abspann das Gefühl, dass es eigentlich gar nichts mehr da wirklich hinzuzufügen gibt, ne?
Ja, zackreisch, warum die GameStar dafür 70% vergeben hat, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich meine, man muss das Spiel sehen, als was es ist, halt eben nicht als...
Ja, nicht als Spiel, sondern halt als interaktive Geschichte.
Hier ist er.
Danke, jetzt geht's spielen, okay?
Zack, zack.
Ich kann immer noch nicht glauben, dass Johnny einfach das Haus an Lily vererbt hat.
Tja, wem hätte er es sonst geben sollen? Uns?
Wobei es wirklich ein ziemlich mieser Ort für Begräbnisse ist.
Wenn es mal einen Erdrutsch gibt, können sie unten mit den Fischen schwimmen.
Noch ein bisschen zu früh für Scherze, oder?
Nein, dafür ist es niemals zu früh.
Netter neuer Klingelton.
Hallo, Eva hier.
Wir sind auf dem Weg.
Neuer Patient?
Neuer Patient.
Dann los.
Fertig.
Es gibt jetzt noch zwei...
Also, was ja noch für Games in diesem Universum, oder was Freebird noch für Games in diesem Universum gemacht hat, ist...
Es gibt zwei...
Ich glaube, es waren zwei...
Mini-Episoden, die in der...
In dieser Firma spielen, wo die beiden angestellt sind.
Da gibt es noch A Birth Story, das ist die Vorgeschichte...
Zum...
Was heißt Vorgeschichte?
Ein Teil der Vorgeschichte zum...
Nächsten Hauptspiel und dann kam jetzt erst vor ein paar Wochen Finding Paradise raus.
Das ist quasi so dann...
Der geistige Nachfolger von To The Moon.
Hat allerdings, außer den beiden...
Ja, außer Nile und Eva, hat es nichts mit To The Moon zu tun.
Es gibt ein paar Referenzen dazu.
Aber...
Es ist ein komplett neuer Patient, eine neue Geschichte.
Und...
Es ist eigentlich genauso gut.
Es geht in eine bisschen andere Richtung, ja?
Das Ende ist auch relativ traurig bei Finding Paradise, ja?
Aber...
Es ist anders.
Finding Paradise ist eher so die Frage...
Braucht man den Scheiß überhaupt?
Oder warum kann man nicht einfach mit seinem Leben zufrieden sein, ohne dass man Eva und Nile braucht?
Ja, Finding Paradise können wir auch noch machen.
Allerdings nicht vielleicht gerade morgen oder so.
Ich muss mir das mal wieder erholen, ey.
Aber ich habe selten eine so schöne Geschichte in einem Spiel gesehen wie hier.
Fertig.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal das Main Theme anmachen.
Der Soundtrack ist echt toll von dem Game.
Also, Leute.
Nochmal, Max, hörst du Hörbücher?
In letzter Zeit habe ich nichts mehr gehört.
Nee.
Ich habe früher recht viele Hörbücher gehört.
Fenris Blue, ich habe das absichtlich auf Twitter nicht angekündigt.
Oh, wir haben es geschafft.
Alles an einem Stück.
So, Leute.
Null Uhr.
Läuft eigentlich Overwatch League noch?
Ja, läuft gerade das letzte Match.
Ich glaube, das gucke ich mir jetzt...
...mit meinem Smartphone im Bett noch an.
Was gibt es denn?
Boston Uprising, San Francisco Shock.
Wie gehen eigentlich die anderen Games aus?
Die Overwatch League Games sind zum größten Teil übelst one-sided.
Ja, ich finde es schön, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Das ist ja einstimmig die Meinung im Chat.
Ich muss nur sagen, ich hatte ein bisschen Schiss vor dem Game.
Vor allem wegen der letzten Stunde.
Weil das halt sehr mitreißend ist.
Aber es ist einfach geil, wie das dann alles zusammenpasst in dem Game.
Ich habe es in auch wenigen Games, sagen wir mal, erlebt, dass...
...dass du den Abspann guckst, ja?
Also sprich, dass das so quasi die Autosequenz und der Abspann...
...wenn du Dinge geguckt hast, dass du dir einfach denkst...
...es ist alles gesagt, was gesagt wurde.
Was gesagt werden musste.
Du brauchst nichts mehr.
Es passt alles zusammen.
Du musst der Sache nichts mehr hinzufügen.
Und ich meine...
...was hätte es...
...für ein besseres Ende geben können, als Johnny und River zusammen zum Mond...
...Händchen halten.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Und...
...gucken, was wir morgen machen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. Tschüss.
Schlaft gut.